When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit. So the best tapas in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at Amex.ca. during the Volvo fall experience event discover exceptional offers and thoughtful design that leaves plenty of room for autumn adventures and see for yourself how Volvo's legendary safety brings peace of mind to every crisp morning commute this september lease a 2026 xe 90 plug-in hybrid from $599 biweekly at 3.99% during the Volvo fall experience event condition supply visit your local Volvo retailer or go to explorevolvo.com.
当您持有美国运通白金卡（Amex Platinum）时，您将尊享独家餐饮体验和年度旅游积分。因此，城中最棒的Tapas小吃可能完全在另一座崭新的城市中。这就是美国运通强大的后盾支持。适用条款与条件。详情请了解 Amex.ca。在沃尔沃秋季体验活动期间，探索卓越的优惠和体贴的设计，为秋天的冒险留出充足的空间，并亲自体验沃尔沃传奇般的安全性如何为每一个清爽的早晨通勤带来安心。今年九月，在沃尔沃秋季体验活动期间，租用一辆 2026 款 XC90 插电式混合动力车，每两周 599 加元起，利率为 3.99%，受条件限制，请访问您当地的沃尔沃零售商或访问 explorevolvo.com。
We have some fun merch news. Yes. We are back with a limited time, a pop-up merch store. Yes, and we have brand new Office Ladies merch for you. It is available September 3rd through September 17th. We've got some classic designs that we know you love, plus an all-new Scranton hot collection. We also have a super cute Finer Things Club tote and a water bottle that says, office ladies sassy since 2019. So if you've been waiting for new Office Ladies merch for yourself,
我们有一些有趣的周边新闻。对的。我们带着限时快闪周边店回归啦。没错，我们为您准备了全新的“办公室女郎”周边商品。它将于 9 月 3 日至 9 月 17 日发售。我们有一些大家肯定都很喜欢的经典设计，外加一个全新的斯克兰顿辣妹系列。我们还有一个超可爱的“美好事物俱乐部”托特包和一个写着“办公室女郎自 2019 年起就很时髦”的水杯。所以，如果您一直都在为自己等待新的“办公室女郎”周边，
your best friend, your sister, your mom, your hubby, now's your chance. Head to shopofficeladies.com and get your order in today. Hello, everybody. Hey there. Guess what? My play just opened. Her play just opened and I went for opening night. You did, but You actually haven't done it yet because we're recording this before the play opened, but I'm hoping that you had a great time and you loved it, lady. I'm sure I had a wonderful time. And I'm sure you were fantastic. And the play was amazing. And I probably ate great food in Chicago. Yeah. What else do you think happened while you were there? Did you meet some wonderful people? I introduced you to the cast, I'm sure. Yeah. I'm also sure I made, you know, really good friends with a perfect stranger at the airport. I'm sure this happened to do that. I probably got to know, like, my cab driver really well, probably know his backstory.
为你最好的朋友、你的姐姐、你的妈妈、你的老公，现在就是你的机会。前往 shopofficeladies.com，今天就下单吧。大家好。大家好。你们猜怎么着？我的话剧刚刚上演。她的戏剧刚刚开演，我去看首演了。你是去看了，但其实你还没去看，因为我们在戏剧上演之前就录制了这期节目，但我希望你度过了一段美好的时光，而且你很喜欢它，女士。我确信我度过了一段美好的时光。而且我确信你表现得棒极了。而且那出戏太棒了。我可能还在芝加哥吃到了很棒的食物。对啊。你觉得你在那里的时候还发生了什么？你遇到了一些了不起的人吗？我敢肯定我把你介绍给演员阵容了。对。我还确信，你知道的，我和机场里一个完完全全的陌生人成为了非常好的朋友。我敢肯定这事发生了。我可能和我的出租车司机混得很熟，甚至可能知道他的背景故事。
Maybe he in another life, you know, before he was a cab driver did river rafting. I probably got really deep into that conversation. These are all of our probabilities because we are actually recording this before you go off. And lady, you know what? I know we're joking around here, but I am really going to miss you. Aw. Yeah. I'm going to miss you.
也许他在另一生中，你知道的，在成为出租车司机之前，曾玩过激流皮划艇。我可能和那场对话进行了非常深入的交流。这些都是我们的推测，因为我们实际上是在你出发之前录制的。而且，女士，你知道吗？我知道我们在这里开玩笑，但我真的会很想念你的。哦。是的。我会想念你的。
I'm going to miss this. I know. I think we might need. need to pop on and do a little Friday chit-chat. We have to. You're going to have all these great Chicago stories. I am going to Iceland. I am going to the penis museum. Yeah, and we're going to need to let people know how that went. All right. Well, listen. On that note, on that note, how do we segue here? Since we're out of town, we wanted to re-air one of our favorite interviews was Zach Woods. You know he played Gabe Lewis on the office. He shares with us what it was like to
我会想念这一切的。我知道。我想我们可能需要上线聊聊天，做一点周五闲聊。我们必须这么做。你会有所有这些精彩的芝加哥故事。我要去冰岛。我要去阴茎博物馆。对，我们需要让大家知道进展如何。好吧。听着。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，我们该怎么在这里过渡呢？既然我们不在城里，我们想重新播放我们最喜欢的采访之一，采访对象是扎克·伍兹。你知道他在《办公室》里饰演盖布·刘易斯。他与我们分享了加入
join the show in the middle of season six. Plus, we ask him about some of his favorite memories on the show, and then he ends up kind of interviewing us. It's such a great conversation. We hope you enjoy it. And we will see you next week with all new episodes. All right, have a good one. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello. Hey, welcome back. Welcome back from Thanksgiving. We hope everybody had good meals
第六季中段的剧组是怎样一种体验。此外，我们还问了他一些在剧组中最美好的回忆，然后他最后竟然反过来采访我们了。这是一场非常棒的对话。我们希望你会喜欢它。我们下周将带着全新的剧集与大家见面。好了，祝你们过得愉快。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作专属的《办公室》终极重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。嘿，欢迎回来。欢迎从感恩节假期回来。我们希望每个人都吃到了美味的食物
and good times. Yes, with friends and family. Some people do Friendsgiving. One of my favorite Thanksgiving's was a Friendsgiving. It was my first year in Los Angeles. I couldn't afford to fly home to see family. Yeah. So me and my other friends who were in L.A., we got together and we had a Thanksgiving. My friend Luda, she's Russian. She brought this Russian vodka. We all got so hammered. That's a Friendsgiving. It was so fun. I actually just found a picture of us. Recently, it came up in my memories. Really? Uh-huh. Yeah. I love that. Yeah, we had traded it. You know, Josh, he bought me the most insane thing. last year for Thanksgiving. And he was like, this is going to be a tradition now. You're
度过了美好的时光。是的，和朋友家人一起。有些人会过“朋友感恩节”。我最喜欢的感恩节之一就是一个朋友感恩节。那是我在洛杉矶的第一年。我买不起回家看家人的机票。是的。所以我和其他在洛杉矶的朋友聚在一起，过了一个感恩节。我的朋友露达，她是俄罗斯人。她带来了这种俄罗斯伏特加。我们所有人都喝得酩酊大醉。那才叫朋友感恩节。太有趣了。我最近刚好找到一张我们的照片。最近，它出现在我的回忆里。真的吗？嗯哼。是的。我喜欢这样。对，我们曾交换过。你知道，乔斯去年感恩节给我买了一件最疯狂的东西。他当时说，这以后要成为一个传统了。你
going to have to wear it every Thanksgiving. I was like, babe. What is it? Okay. You know, I'm always cold. And I always want a cozy onesie. I'm like, babe, get me a onesy. Get me a cozy onesie. Okay. Lady, it's a turkey. A turkey one. First of all, it's a one size fits all. So it's enormous. Do you eat in it? Is you wear it all day? No, I can't. It's like wearing a giant blanket. I can't eat in it, but I do put it on. I've only done. This is my second year. Okay. I don't know what the tradition of this turkey onesie is going to be, but I told him, here's what I'll do.
每个感恩节都得穿它。我说，宝贝。是什么呀？好吧。你知道的，我总是很冷。而且我总是想要一件舒适的连体衣。我说，宝贝，给我买件连体衣。给我买一件舒适的连体衣。好吧。女士，是一只火鸡。火鸡连体衣。首先，它是均码的。所以它大得离谱。你穿着它吃饭吗？你整天都穿着它吗？不，我不能。这就像穿着一条巨型毯子。我不能穿着它吃饭，但我确实把它穿上了。我只穿过。这是我的第二年。好吧。我不知道这件火鸡连体衣的传统会变成怎样，但我告诉他，我是这么打算的。
Because he thinks it's so cute. I put it on and I watched the Macy's Day parade in my turkey onesie. Okay. And then, you know, we get the food prep going, but I don't wear it to the actual Thanksgiving dinner. What is it that Josh thinks this is so funny? I look like a tiny, tiny turkey. Do you watch football? Oh, yeah.
因为他觉得这太可爱了。我把它穿上，穿着我的火鸡连体衣看梅西百货感恩节大游行。好吧。然后，你知道的，我们开始准备食物，但我不会穿着它去吃真正的感恩节晚餐。为什么乔斯觉得这这么搞笑？我看起来像一只极其微小的火鸡。你看橄榄球吗？哦，是的。
Football's always on. So when I got into football, I was dating a guy who was from Detroit. And you know, Detroit plays every Thanksgiving. And the Cowboys. Yes, now I'm married to a Dallas man. Yeah. Now I'm a Cowboys fan. Oh, yeah.
橄榄球总是在播。所以当我开始看橄榄球时，我在和一个底特律出身的家伙交往。你知道的，底特律每个感恩节都有比赛。还有牛仔队。对，我现在嫁给了一个达拉斯男人。对。现在我是牛仔队的球迷。哦，是的。
Yeah. So Cowboys, every Thanksgiving. You've got to work the meal around it. Half of my family's from Texas, lady. Yes, you know. What am I saying? I know. Of course.
是的。所以牛仔队，每个感恩节。你必须围绕它来安排饭局。我有一半的家人来自得克萨斯州，女士。是的，你知道的。我还在说什么呢？我知道。当然。
Well, listen, we have a really exciting show for you today. I don't even know what to say about it. It's maybe one of my favorite episodes we've ever done. Jenna and I are in love with this interview, you guys. I'm sorry, I said an interview, but it was so wonderful. Well, Jenna, you tell everyone. Well, we got to sit down with Zach Woods. As you know, Zach played Gabe Lewis on 52 episodes of The Office.
好了，听着，我们今天为您准备了一个非常精彩的节目。我甚至不知道该说些什么。这可能是我做过的最喜欢的剧集之一。珍娜和我爱死这次采访了，伙计们。不好意思，我说是一次采访，但它实在是太美妙了。好吧，珍娜，你来告诉大家吧。好吧，我们和扎克·伍兹坐下来聊了聊。如你所知，扎克在《办公室》的 52 集里饰演了盖布·刘易斯。
He was on from season six to season nine. We talk all about it. We talk about his entire time on the show and other things. Here's the thing. He's just so interesting and he's so smart. and funny, and we would be talking about the show, and then he would throw you and I, like a curveball question. Like a deep, like question about what it means to be just human and alive.
他从第六季一直演到第九季。我们聊了所有这些。我们聊了他在剧组的全部时光以及其他事情。事情是这样的。他是如此有趣，如此聪明，而且幽默风趣，我们本在讨论这部剧，然后他会抛给你和我一个，类似于意料之外的问题。一个深刻的、关于仅仅作为人类和活着意味着什么的问题。
Like, so fun. Oh, I just can't wait for everyone to listen to this interview. I just love it. Well, you guys, Zach is currently working on a new stop motion animation series called In the Know. He's the co-creator, the director, and star of the show, and Greg Daniels is one of the executive producers. So you know this is going to be good. The show premieres on Peacock in the New Year, so be on the lookout. Yeah, we'll share about it in stories. But you know what? I think we take a quick break and get to this interview because it's so fantastic. You're going to love it. And the
太有趣了。哦，我简直迫不及待地想让大家听听这次采访了。我太喜欢了。好了，伙计们，扎克目前正在制作一部名为《知情者》（In the Know）的全新定格动画系列。他是该剧的共同创作者、导演兼主演，格雷格·丹尼尔斯是执行制片人之一。所以你知道这一定会很棒。该剧将于新年期间在 Peacock 首播，敬请关注。是的，我们会在快讯中分享相关内容的。但你知道吗？我想我们应该快速休息一下，然后开始这次采访，因为它太棒了。你会爱上它的。而且，
second half, dare I say, is even better than the first. It keeps getting better and better. Here it is. marty scenting. Pura's sleek diffuser connects to your phone so you can swap between fragrances, set schedules, and create the perfect autumn mood with just a tap. From cinnamon and crisp apple to rich cozy woods, Pura makes every moment feel like fall. Upgrade your home today. Shop the fall collection now at pura.com. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support, maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom for life advice, but not everyone is a therapist. You can find your right match with BetterHelp.
我敢说，下半部分甚至比上半部分还要精彩。它越来越好。这就是采访内容。Pura 的时尚香薰扩散器可连接至您的手机，让您只需轻轻一按，即可在不同香气之间切换、设置时间表，并营造出完美的秋日氛围。从肉桂和爽脆的苹果到浓郁舒适的木质香，Pura 让每个时刻都散发着秋天的气息。今天就升级您的家居。现在就在 pura.com 选购秋季系列。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道的，有时我们会去一些有趣的地方寻求支持，比如理发师、咖啡师，或者是浴室里的某个陌生人来获取生活建议，但并不是每个人都是治疗师。您可以通过 BetterHelp 找到合适的人选。
BetterHelp therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp does the initial matching work for you, so you can focus on your therapy goals. You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals
BetterHelp 的治疗师经过临床培训和认证。他们按照严格的行为准则工作，并在美国拥有完全的执照。而且 BetterHelp 会为您完成最初的匹配工作，这样您就可以专注于您的治疗目标。您将获得一份简短的问卷，帮助确定您的需求和偏好，然后他们会为您匹配一位获得执照的治疗师。作为全球最大的在线心理治疗提供商，BetterHelp 可以为您提供接触具有各种专业知识的心理健康专家的途径。
with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp. H-E-L-P-com slash office ladies Hello, Zach!
通过 BetterHelp 找到属于你的那个人。我们的听众在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 首次订阅可享 9 折优惠。网址是 BetterHelp.com/officeladies。你好，扎克！
Hello, Zach! How wonderful to see you! How wonderful to see you and you. Should we tell people we've actually been chatting off mic for like 30 minutes? Oh, seriously, we've been talking for half an hour, but we decided we should probably get to the podcast. Yes. They literally said, we're going to do a big fake hello, and then you immediately told it on yourself. You're giving away our secrets. Sorry. I'm going to do it.
你好，扎克！很高兴见到你！很高兴见到你，也见到你。我们要不要告诉大家，我们其实已经在话筒外聊了大约 30 分钟了？哦，真的，我们已经聊了半个小时了，但我们决定还是应该开始录播客了。是的。他们刚才literally说，我们要假装来一个盛大的问候，然后你马上就把自己给出卖了。你在泄露我们的秘密。对不起。我要这么做。
An office man, office ladies podcast, or I tell the stories behind the office ladies podcast. Okay. Oh. It would be like Russian dolls. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. So you listen to office ladies and then you break down our podcast. Right.
一个办公室男人，办公室女郎的播客，还是我来讲述办公室女郎播客背后的故事？好吧。哦。这就像俄罗斯套娃一样。是的。哦，天哪。所以你听办公室女郎的播客，然后剖析我们的播客。对。
And I'll have you guys on to talk about the podcast when you're talking about the. This might be a genius idea. Well, we're going to kick things off with the question we ask all of our guests to start, which is, how did you get your job on the office? It's a good question. Alison Jones, who you guys both know. was like a fairy godmother to me. Like she, for people who, I mean, I know you've talked about her on the show, but she was the casting director for the show
然后我会邀请你们两个来谈谈你们谈论播客时的播客。这可能是一个天才的想法。好吧，我们要以一个我们向所有嘉宾提出的老问题开始，那就是：你是如何得到《办公室》这份工作的？这是个好问题。艾莉森·琼斯（Alison Jones），你们俩都认识。就像我的仙女教母一样。就像她，对于那些——我的意思是，我知道你们在节目中谈论过她——但她是该剧的选角导演，
and like basically American comedy for a decade or more, right? And she brought me in to her office, which was in Gower Studios, where I guess they used to shoot, I love Lucy and stuff. Wow. Right? Isn't that right? I think so, yeah. It was like one of these old Hollywood things. It's got like plaques everywhere.
基本上统治了美国喜剧界十年或更久，对吧？她把我叫进她的办公室，那个办公室在高尔工作室（Gower Studios），我猜他们以前在那里拍《我爱露西》之类的东西。哇。对吧？是不是这样？我想是的，没错。就像那些老好莱坞的事情之一。到处都有牌匾。
Right. Yeah. And like plaster. And it just feels like, you know, whatever. You can, like, it's like where you can imagine, like, Clark Gable stumbling into there after he, like, killed someone with him be, like, telling his publicist, like, bury it. But anyway, uh... Poor Clark Gable. Sorry, Clark Gable.
对吧。是的。还有石膏。感觉就像，你知道的，诸如此类。你可以，就像，就像你可以想象的那样，比如克拉克·盖博在杀了一个人之后跌跌撞撞地走进那里，对他的公关人员说，比如把它掩盖掉。不管怎样，呃……可怜的克拉克·盖博。对不起，克拉克·盖博。
You probably never killed anyone. I'm sorry. I just feel like I, you know, like, old Hollywood stars were always killing people and telling their publicists to go over and get rid of it. Yeah. Yeah. She was just some girl. No one's going to know. Yeah, anyway, but, uh, got distracted.
你可能从来没杀过任何人。我很抱歉。我只是觉得，你知道的，老好莱坞明星总是杀人然后告诉他们的公关去把尸体处理掉。是啊。是啊。她只是个普通女孩。没人会知道的。是的，不管怎样，但是，呃……分心了。
Alison Jones. Allison Jones. Gower. So I remember. a meeting with her, and I'd done this movie called In the Loop, and she'd seen it, and she brought me in for a meeting, and I really hadn't done anything except for this one little independent movie, and she talked to me for like an hour, and then at the end of it, she just went, I'm going to help you, which is such a wild thing for someone to say in Hollywood, you know,
艾莉森·琼斯。艾莉森·琼斯。高尔。所以我记得。和她开过一次会，我拍过一部叫《因果循环》（In the Loop）的电影，她看过，她叫我去开会，我除了这部独立小电影之外真的什么都没拍过，她跟我聊了一个小时左右，然后在最后，她只是说，我要帮你在好莱坞，有人说出这样的话简直太疯狂了，你知道吗，
and then even a wilder thing to mean and follow through on, and then she got me a meeting with Greg, Daniels, and Paul, and they just gave me a part on the office, which is a show that I had been obsessively watching. I felt like I won a contest. Like, you know what I mean? Like you went a raffle and you can do like a walk on on like a TV show. Like I felt like it was so bizarre to me that she almost like to a suspicious degree where it's like, like, who's going to jump out and say gotcha? Right. Yeah. Or is she going to like, am I going to get a call in here or Alison Jones just like throw napalm in one of my enemy's faces? It's like time for. Payback.
更疯狂的是她不仅这么说还真的兑现了，然后她给我安排了和格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）以及保罗（Paul）的会面，他们直接给了我在《办公室》里的一个角色，这是一部我一直在痴迷观看的剧。我觉得我中了大奖。就像，你知道我的意思吗？就像你中了彩票，你可以在一个电视节目里跑龙套。我觉得这一切对我都太诡异了，几乎到了让人怀疑的程度，就好像，谁会跳出来说“抓到你了”？对。是啊，或者她会，我会接到一个电话，然后艾莉森·琼斯直接把凝固汽油弹泼在我其中一个敌人的脸上了？就像是时候了。
You know, you have to. Yeah, exactly. And then, yeah, and then I just got this part. And then I moved into this house in Echo Park where it was a basement and I'm tall and there were these rafters. So I had to constantly duck. Like, the ceiling was to those. I was constantly doing these like kind of body rolls around my living room.
你知道的，你必须这么做。对，没错。然后，是的，然后我就得到了这个角色。接着我搬进了回声公园（Echo Park）的一栋房子，那是个地下室，我个子很高，那里有横梁。所以我必须不停地低头。天花板就在那。我不得不在我的客厅里不停地做那种类似身体滚翻的动作。
And I was, somehow she got wind of this and she was like, oh, I have an empty condo in Beachwood Canyon, which I'll give to you for a song, basically. And then she gave me this like. beautiful condo to live in for like very low rent where they used to house it was like a dormitory for starlets back in the like
不知怎么的，她风闻了这件事，然后她说，哦，我在比奇伍德峡谷（Beachwood Canyon）有一间空公寓，基本上可以白菜价租给你。然后她给了我这个。美丽的公寓，租金非常便宜，他们以前把那里当作宿舍，是给星探挖掘的年轻女演员住的，在
it was like the MGM gals would be there and in the basement there was a beauty salon where they had to go through the works before they could go out into the world because they didn't want anyone
就像米高梅（MGM）的女孩们会呆在那里，在地下室里有一个美容院，她们必须在那里经过一番彻底的打扮才能走到世界上，因为他们不想让任何人
seeing like the MGM girls looking less than their best basically so I was effectively an MGM girl thanks to Allison Jones but I'm being long winded and I'm a little nervous because we're talking about Alice I'll be less long winded
看到米高梅的女孩们看起来不够完美，基本上是这样。所以多亏了艾莉森·琼斯，我实际上成了一个米高梅女孩。但我有点啰嗦了，而且我有点紧张，因为我们在谈论艾莉森。我会少说废话的。
but I will just say Alison Jones I will never be able to adequately express the difference that Allison Jones made in my life. Professionally, residentially, personally, just like that woman just like tap me with her magic wand and gave me my life as a, you know, in L.A., basically. I mean, we feel the same way about Allison Jones. Yeah. I had a general meeting with her and she sort of did the same thing. It was like one hour meeting, hey, I like you.
但我只想说，艾莉森·琼斯，我永远无法充分表达艾莉森·琼斯在我生命中带来的改变。在职业上，居住上，个人上，就像那个女人用她的魔杖轻触了我一下，基本上给了我在洛杉矶的生活。我的意思是，我们对艾莉森·琼斯也有同样的感受。是的。我和她开过一次例行会议，她差不多也做了同样的事情。那是一次一个小时的会议，“嘿，我喜欢你。
I think you're talented. I'm going to help you out. And then just called me in for years for a little bit parts. And then eventually, how lucky am I that the person who decided to help me was hired to cast the office? That was just my good luck. Yeah. You know? Because then she was like, well, I'm going to have you meet on this new show, The Office.
我觉得你很有才华。我要帮帮你。”然后连续多年叫我去演一些小角色。然后最终，我是多么幸运，那个决定帮助我的人被雇来负责《办公室》的选角？这纯粹是我的好运。对吧。你知道吗？因为随后她说，“好吧，我要让你去参加这部新剧《办公室》的面试。”
So it was the same thing. And I've heard people tell this story about Alison Jones many, many times. It's crazy. And she has like this kind of like flinty New Englander quality where if you try to they tell this to her face, it's just like, it's like shining light on a vampire or something. She just, she refuses the accolades, right? Yeah. That's right.
所以是一样的。我听很多人讲过这个关于艾莉森·琼斯的故事，讲了很多很多次。太疯狂了。她有一种那种坚定的新英格兰人的特质，如果你当面把这些告诉她，感觉就像，就像把光照在吸血鬼身上一样。她拒绝接受赞美，对吧？是的。没错。
She can't tolerate it. It's just like, that's been my experience anyway, where you try to, like, look her in the eyes and be like, thank you. Yeah. She's like, no. No, it's fine. Here, have a homemade cookie I just made. Because she always has, like, delicious cookies. Right.
她无法忍受。这就是我的体验，无论如何，当你试图看着她的眼睛说谢谢时。是的。她会说，不。不，没关系。来吧，吃一块我刚做的 homemade 曲奇。因为她总是带着，比如，美味的曲奇。对。
She just feels like that awesome, warm aunt that's going to look out for you. It's true. Allison, we love you. I love you. FYI, if you haven't gathered it. Besides in the loop, which I remember in which everyone was talking about when you came to work with us, it's a great movie. Besides that, what was your background? Like, do you have an improv background?
她感觉就像那种棒极了、温暖的阿姨，会照顾你。确实如此。艾莉森，我们爱你。我爱你。顺便说一句，如果你还没明白的话。除了《因果循环》，我记得那部电影，你来和我们一起工作时每个人都在谈论它，这是一部好电影。除此之外，你的背景是什么？比如，你有什么即兴表演的背景吗？
Yeah, I started doing improv at Upright Citizens Brigade in New York, and I mostly just thought I was going to do that. I remember talking to someone and being like, I just want to get a temp job and do improv at night. That was eight years of my life. It's fun, right? Yeah. Did you feel like when you were doing that, did it feel unsatisfying in some fundamental one? No, it was the most fun. Right.
是的，我开始在纽约的正义公民帮（Upright Citizens Brigade）进行即兴表演，我本来以为我只会做那个。我记得跟某个人聊过，说我只想找一份临时工作，然后在晚上做即兴表演。那是我生命中的八年。很有趣，对吧？对。当你在做那个的时候，你觉得它在某种根本上无法令人满意吗？不，那是最有趣的。对。
It was the most fun because the job I didn't really care about. I just needed to pay bills so I could go do improv. And then you're with like, do you have a community? Yeah, and they all are like-minded and we were so into it. We were probably really obnoxious. Well, I used to teach too when I was in New York to help, like I'd like teaching and also it helped me survive. But I remember once being in a cab in New York and going past an improv, theater and seeing all these adults outside and they were like throwing like imaginary knives
那是最有趣的，因为这份工作我其实不在乎。我只需要付账单，这样我就可以去做即兴表演。然后你和一群人在一起，你有社区吗？是的，他们都志同道合，我们对此非常投入。我们可能真的很讨厌。好吧，我在纽约的时候也教书，为了，就像我喜欢教书，而且这也帮助我生存下来。但我记得有一次在纽约坐出租车，路过一个即兴表演剧场，看到外面有这群成年人，他们就像是在互相投掷假想的
to each other or whatever. They were doing some like warm up. It was so humiliating and so you could not look nerdier and less cool. And these people, I just felt my heart swell in my chest. Like seeing these like grown adults just like kind of they look so happy. They were just like being so cringe, so happily out in public in New York on the street, I was just like, God bless you guys. Like, it's so sweet. Like, I found it so moving.
飞刀或者别的什么。他们正在做某种热身。这太羞耻了，你看起来不可能更书呆子气、更不酷了。而这些人，我能感觉到我的心脏在胸口膨胀。就像看到这些成年人只是，他们看起来那么开心。他们只是在纽约的街道上，那么大方地、那么快乐地当众出丑，我当时就想，上帝保佑你们。这太美妙了。我发现这太感人了。
You're like, I want to end. I thought it was so perfect when they made the choice to have Michael Scott in an improv group. It's so perfect. Like, I took improv classes with a Michael Scott. Oh, my God. It's mostly Michael Scott. Yeah.
你就会想，我想加入。当他们决定让迈克尔·斯科特加入一个即兴表演小组时，我觉得这太完美了。太完美了。就像，我和一个迈克尔·斯科特一起上过即兴表演课。哦，天哪。基本上全是迈克尔·斯科特。是啊。
Oh, my gosh. How much were you told about the character, Gabe? Did you know it was going to be like a long arc? No. I didn't know much. It's a pretty foggy memory because I think because it felt like such a, I felt like such a raffle winner where it's like you can be on your favorite show. It created like such a rush of anxiety that like I've never experienced anything like before since.
哦，天哪。关于盖布这个角色，你被告知了多少？你知道这会是一个很长的故事线吗？不。我知道的不多。这是一段相当模糊的记忆，我想是因为我觉得自己像个中彩票的人，你可以出演你最喜欢的节目。它产生了如潮水般的焦虑，这种焦虑是我以前从未体验过的。
Like to be like completely inexperienced as a TV actor and to be thrust into a show where you're like, you know what I mean? It's just like it was really overwhelming. And I remember, like, when I first moved out here, right before I started filming, I remember there was, like, some moment. This is a really crazy compromising moment. I was at Walmart. First of all, I didn't know how to drive because I've been living in New York. So I had to, like, as an adult man, go to Pennsylvania and have my father, like, reteach me to drive because I was like, I'm going to be in L.A.
作为一个毫无经验的电视演员，被猛地推到一个你，你知道我的意思吗？这实在是太让人喘不过气来了。我记得，当我刚搬到这里时，就在我开始拍摄之前，我记得有那么一个时刻。这是一个非常疯狂、身处妥协的时刻。我在沃尔玛。首先，我不会开车，因为我一直住在纽约。所以我不得不作为一个成年男子去宾夕法尼亚州，让我父亲重新教我开车，因为我想，我要去洛杉矶了。
You have to teach me to drive. So my dad taught me to drive, like, some weird, like, little short film or something. Like, and then I remember when we started shooting, driving terrified me so much that I would show up on set and my jaw would be so clenched that I had a hard time saying words. So I would take CDs, Frank Sinatra CDs, and I would put them in the car and force myself to sing along with old blue eyes so that my jaw would stay open so that I wouldn't show up with like rigor mortis face. Yeah. And then I think before I'd even shot my first scene. being in a Walmart, buying like multiple humidifiers and lozenges and shit because I was like, I'm going to lose my voice and then I'm not going to be able to do it and I'm going to. I was so panicked and I was worried I was going to forget my lines. So I was like muttering my lines in a Walmart. For some reason, I didn't get a basket. So I just had like armfuls of like humidifiers and lozenges just like muttering like my lines to myself like a crazy person. So what I really remember from that time is just the white hot panic of like, you know, like. Were you? prone to losing your voice? What was this anxiety about losing your voice? I was prone to losing
你必须教我开车。所以我爸教我开车，就像拍某种奇怪的短片一样。然后我记得当我们开始拍摄时，开车让我感到非常恐惧，以至于我一到片场，下巴就紧咬着，以至于我很难说出话来。所以我拿 CD，弗兰克·辛纳屈（Frank Sinatra）的 CD，我把它们放在车里，强迫自己跟着这位老蓝眼唱歌，这样我的下巴就能保持张开，这样我出现的时候就不会顶着一张像尸僵一样的脸。是的。然后我想，甚至在我拍摄第一场戏之前。在沃尔玛里，买了一堆加湿器、喉糖和乱七八糟的东西，因为我想，我要失去我的声音了，然后我就没法完成工作了，我就会……我当时恐慌极了，我担心我会忘词。所以我就像个疯子一样在沃尔玛里咕哝着我的台词。不知为什么，我没有拿篮子。所以我手里抱满了加湿器和喉糖，像个疯子一样自言自语地咕哝着台词。所以我对那段时光的真实记忆，只有那种炽热的恐慌，就像……你当时……容易失声吗？这种对失声的焦虑是怎么回事？我很容易
my mind. I was like, I put you in the Walmart. I think it was just like anything. You know, you have like free-ranging. Sometimes I feel like anxiety is just like a giant like military helicopter that needs someplace to land. Yeah. And it was like, oh, today it'll be landing on the landing pad of like vocal anxiety. Tomorrow it'll be like whatever that I'll, you know, some weird hypochondriacal thing in a different direction. Yes. Yes. So I don't remember what they told me, but I didn't think I was, I thought it might just be a few episodes and then they gave me more and I was like, wow, that's great. Do you remember your first day on set? Yeah. What did you shoot your very first day? I think the first thing I shot was a to camera, like one of the interviews. A talking head.
失去理智。我当时就把你放在沃尔玛里。我想这就像任何事情一样。你知道，你会有那种随意的……有时我觉得焦虑就像一架需要找地方降落的巨型军用直升机。是的。然后就会变成，哦，今天它会降落在声乐焦虑的降落坪上。明天它就会变成别的什么，你知道的，向另一个方向发展的某种奇怪的疑病症。是的。是的。所以我记不清他们对我说了什么，但我没觉得自己会演很久，我以为可能只是几集，然后他们给了我更多戏份，我当时就想，哇，那太棒了。你还记得你第一天在片场的情景吗？记得。你第一天拍的第一场戏是什么？我记得我拍的第一件事是面向镜头，比如其中一个采访。独白镜头。
Talking head. Okay. Yeah. That's a good way to start actually because it's just you. No one is dependent on your line for timing. You're not driving a scene. Right. So I think that's actually a really smart way to start. They might have done that on purpose too. What was your first impression coming on the set? Well, John Krasinski directed the episode that I was doing. And I remember something happened on set and it like took longer than they were expecting. So I was sort of in my trailer just churning. And then they called me to set. And I think John knew that I was kind of like pent up and terrified. And so he just like, even though I'm sure it had been a long day and there was a lot left to shoot, he like let me just improvise a lot in the talking head. I doubt they
独白镜头。好吧。是的，这其实是一个很好的开始，因为只有你一个人。没有人依赖你的台词来把握时机。你不需要推动一场戏。对。所以我觉得这其实是一个非常聪明的开始。他们可能也是故意这么做的。你来到片场的第一印象是什么？嗯，约翰·克拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）导演了我当时正在拍的那集。我记得片场发生了一些事，花费的时间比他们预期的要长。所以我有点在我的保姆车里焦虑翻腾。然后他们叫我去片场。我想约翰知道我当时有点积怨且惊恐万分。所以他只是——尽管我确信那是漫长的一天，还有很多镜头要拍——他还是让我有很多即兴发挥的空间。我怀疑他们
used any of it. But it just was like, it let me relax. And he was so kind about it. The big thing that I remember, and part of why I was excited to do this, is because I'm not good at staying in touch with people and stuff, but I feel yeah, that I feel like is important to me to communicate to people who listen to this, which is
用了其中的任何镜头。但这就像，它让我放松了下来。他对此真的太友好了。我记得最深刻的一件事，这也是我兴奋于做这件事的部分原因，因为我不擅长和人们保持联系之类的，但我确实觉得，是的，我觉得这对我来说很重要，要传达给听这个节目的人，那就是
the level of kindness and hospitality that was extended to me on that show was bizarre. Like, if you're in the late seasons of a TV show that has like such a deep bench of amazing characters and some new person shows up who's
在这个节目中给予我的那种善良和好客的程度是不可思议的。听着，如果你身处一部电视剧的后期季，剧中已经有一批才华横溢的角色，而某个新人出现了，
going to suck up even more oxygen, eat up more story time. You know what I mean? It would be very easy to understand if people were not all that receptive to that, especially if it's someone who's like a rookie who's still just like learning about like, okay, what's an eyeline? How do I like, what's a mark? You know what I mean? Like stuff, like just very rookie stuff that I'm having to learn on the go. Like it would be totally reasonable if people had a kind of professional detachment from that person. But everyone was so ostentatiously kind to me. Ostentatious makes it sound bad.
还要吸走更多的氧气，吃掉更多的剧情时间。你知道我的意思吗？如果大家对此并不是那么接受，那完全是可以理解的，特别是如果这个人还是一个仍在学习的新人，比如，好吧，什么是视线？我该如何，什么是定位？你知道我的意思吗？就像东西，非常新人的东西，我不得不边学边做。如果大家对这样的人有一种职业上的冷漠，那是完全合乎情理的。但每个人都对我表现得那么大肆地友善。“大肆”听起来有点贬义。
Just generous, kind. Like, you guys were so lovely to me. You guys were so sweet to me and inclusive. I remember, like, I would just sort of camp out at, like, Phyllis and Leslie's desk and watch them, like, shop for, they were both, like, decorating their houses. And they were like. Yes, she was looking for a gate for, like, I think two years. More, maybe.
就是慷慨，友善。就像，你们对我太美好了。你们对我太甜美了，而且很有包容性。我记得，我基本上会在菲利斯（Phyllis）和莱斯利（Leslie）的办公桌旁安营扎寨，看她们购物，她们俩当时都在装修房子。她们就像。是的，她一直在找一扇门，大概，我想两年时间。甚至更久。
Yeah. We looked at every gate. I just remember basically, yeah, like gate shopping with Leslie and Phyllis and like they would show me and they would be so nice and joke around with me. I remember Kate Flannery really went out of her way, Oscar, all the, and not just in a kind, again, not just in a perfunctory, like, professional way. They'd invite me to their houses. You guys would include me in like social stuff. I just, it was so, it was like the photo negative of what happened to the character Gabe, right? Like, Gabe is like this like unfortunate, creepy guy shows up and is immediately and utterly ostracist.
是的。我们看过了每一扇门。我只记得基本上，是的，和莱斯利和菲利斯一起逛门市，她们会给我看，而且她们对我非常好，跟我开玩笑。我记得凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）真的特意照顾我，还有奥斯卡（Oscar），所有人，而且不仅仅是那种善良，再次强调，不仅仅是敷衍的、职业的方式。他们会邀请我去他们家。你们会把我纳入社交活动中。我只是，这太……这就像盖布这个角色的照片底片，对吧？就像，盖布就像是个不幸的、诡异的家伙出现，然后立刻被彻底排挤。
It was like, yeah, it was the exact opposite where I was like, oh my God, look at this. Like this group of people is just like so envelopingly sweet. So that was life-changing because I was already so fragile and terrified because it was such a new experience. And I wanted so desperately to do a good job. And to be met with that kind of generosity of spirit was, I think, formative for me. I mean, we loved the character Gabe. I mean, in rewatching, like, Gabe has made us. laugh so hard. But one of the things we've been most excited about doing this podcast is being able
这就好比，是的，这完全是相反的，当时我想，天哪，看这个。这群人简直是……如此包罗万象地甜美。所以这改变了我的人生，因为我当时已经非常脆弱和害怕，因为这是一次如此崭新的经历。我太渴望把工作做好了。那种被以这种精神慷慨相待的体验，我想，对我的塑造至关重要。我的意思是，我们很喜欢盖布这个角色。我的意思是，在重温时，盖布让我们笑得前仰后合。但我们做这个播客最让人兴奋的事情之一，就是能够
to reconnect with these people that were such an amazing chapter of our life. And you're one of those people. We've talked about you so much. We're so happy you're here. I mean, we still talked about the gift you brought to my Yankee Swap Christmas party, which was a sarcophagus, like, jewelry box. It was the gift that everyone wanted. I mean, like, Legend gift. Thank you. I mean, that's like white elephant stuff is like a real source of anxiety, right? Because it's like, it feels like like a moral spiritual test.
与这些曾是我们生命中如此精彩篇章的人重新建立联系。而你就是其中之一。我们谈论你太多了。很高兴你能来。我的意思是，我们还在谈论你带到我的洋基交换圣诞派对上的礼物，那是一个石棺形状的首饰盒。那是人人都想要的礼物。我的意思是，就像，传奇礼物。谢谢。我的意思是，这就好比“白象”礼品交换就像是真正的焦虑来源，对吧？因为这感觉就像是一场道德精神测试。
So I'm glad that I passed. You passed and I have the sarcophagus. Yes. It's mine. Yeah. I went home with it. Yeah. I have it on my bookshelf.
And it's not cursed or anything, right? It doesn't seem like it. Good. Okay, cool. Yeah, it seems like it had you. I hadn't actively pursued a curse, but if there's a small sarcophagus, the odds that it has some sort of curse. It's been good so far. It's doing great for you. It was a heated battle that you won. I also off topic here, but in anticipation of talking to you today, I sort of went back through old
emails and I have some great photos of you that I sent a long, long time ago to you to probably an old email, but they're great. They're just of you hanging out on set. So I need to make sure you get those. I would love that. Yeah. I would love that. Yeah. Not that I was a creeper taking pictures of you. There's like my camera in the men's room which I got a lot of candid snaps. No. But I did.
I found a few when we were at Shrewt farms. Oh yeah. So I'm going to make sure you get those. With Grobin. Yes. With Josh. That's a really surreal moment. Like I'm in a farm with Josh Grobin and like all these people have been watching
for years. It's just such a weird. Where am I? Yeah. Did someone like dose me with acid and I'm like just back in my like in my like in my like basement apartment in house kitchen having like a weird fever dream yeah so i watched like your first couple of episodes which must have been so insane because you're talking about being new and everything so like there's the scene where you enter dunder mithlin for the first time and dwight is holding
a giant tray of hot dogs and then Aaron andy sing the sobri song yes that is so crazy and then the next episode, you're, like, wrestling some great Danes and you're talking to Kathy Bates? Kathy Bates. I know, that's crazy. When did they tell you that you would be working with Kathy Bates? You know, this is not a satisfying answer, but the truth is, again, it's just this sort of, like, pummeling. Of anxiety.
Like, I don't even know. I felt like I was, like, being beaten into a happy gang or so they're just like, it's like, like, I don't know. Like, Kathy Bates, like, the office, like, you're going to, like, you're driving. And you're going to be, like, it just felt like this kind of like word jumble. of like, I don't know. What's next? Yeah, I just felt like, like, I don't remember finding it out.
Like, it's like the fog of war. I'm just like, I don't remember. That's very funny. We were so nervous about Kathy Bates being on set. Really? Yeah. What were you nervous about just that she would tell me? Just anything?
Just like making eye contact. And she was such a presence. And then she was so kind. I think it was just her stature and her body of work. and we had avoided for so long having like these big name actors on the show and so this was kind of a turning point and it was very shocking.
It felt like, you know? Yeah. So my hair colorist had once colored Kathy Bates' hair. This is Janice. And he told me this like years ago, you know, and just, you know, when hairdressers just tell you their lore while they're doing your hair. And he's like, well, you know, I used to color Kathy Bates' hair.
and oh, what a woman, and he just, like, so admired her and all this. He didn't gossip, but he just did name drop that he had colored her hair. So when I knew she was coming on the show, I had to resist that urge, you know, when, like, the second I saw her not to be like, we have the same hair colorist. Hi, I'm Jenna. Our hair colorist, he colored your hair once. Welcome to the show. I'm so impressed that. that you suppress that, because I know that would come
just tumbling out of my mouth. I held it. I can't remember for how long. I think I made it several days. And then I did finally say, you know, Robert Hickland hair colorist? I think we, I think he,
oh, yes, Bobby, yes, I know him, yes, wonderful guy. We should be best friends now. Well, that was my next line. So we are clearly best friends then. Same hair colorist. So much in common. I'm your emergency contact. Yeah, exactly.
Let me ask you, so because for many people, you are that. Like, in other words, when people see you, right, it generates the same feelings in them that Kathy Bage generated in you. So what is the version, like, when people come up to you guys and are like, actually, did you know that we shared a, you know, whatever, we stay in the same summer camp cabin, da-da-da-da, like, does it feel alienating to you when people do that? Or does it feel nice or does it just depend on the person? Like, well, I guess what I'm asking is like, or maybe is it okay to ask you guys? Yeah, yes, please. What is the version of being approached in a situation like that where maybe it's not just like in the airport, but it's like a situation that has some containment that feels good to you versus the one that feels like, like if you're Kathy Bates, how do you want someone to approach you? Well, I'll say that I just did the Mean Girls movie musical.
I play the mom. Yay! And after I got on the set and I like was working, I called Angela and I was like, Angela, we are now like the old lady, like the people, like these kids and the crew and stuff, they're treating me like the way we were around like Kathy Bates or around some of these like people who had like the resumes and all that kind of stuff. I'm like, it's so weird. And it feels like it was so bizarre because I was like, oh, I'm like not at all worthy of your, what do you call it? Like they're just giving me like, like, yes, like sort of like, we thank you so much for doing our film. And the directors were just like, we can't believe we got you. And I'm like, you can't.
I've like, it's the mean girls movie musical. I feel like people are lining up to do this. You're being so overly kind to me, but I do remember that. Like when we would be at an award show, like someone from a television show that we had watched, you get a chance to meet them, or they give you an award or something. You're like, oh, my God, I can't believe this person. I was like, we're the old timers now. Yeah. We're the old timers who have been in the biz for a while.
And I actually thought it was really cool. I'm still very humbled by it all that, you know, that I got to stop. temping and got to, you know, take the skills I learned from my improv classes and get paid to do something I love. It's still very humbling to me that people watch the show, enjoy the show, want to watch me be silly or whatever it is, you know? I always feel like I won the lottery. So I'm still taken aback by it, like what you're saying, it just, I don't think that'll ever go away. I'm still, I still can't believe I got to do this, you know? I wonder if Kathy Bates had that feeling.
Yeah, maybe. I will tell you, here's an example of when maybe it's not fun or appropriate. I, towards the end of my pregnancy, was having some pain. And they said, okay, let's get you to the specialist for this special kind of sonogram where they can make sure everything's okay. I was having a lot of pain in my pelvis. So I met with this person I've never met before, and he's conducting the sonogram. You know, I'm just like laying there.
And he's like, so is Dwight going to be stopping? And I was like, you mean a fictional character I'm in a television show with that is not the father of my baby? No. What? Like, I'm coming to you because I have pain in my pelvis. That's so horrible. Giving me a sonogram and I'm laying here, feeling so exposed.
And you asked me, I knew he was like, and he had been like 20 minutes. So he'd been holding on to that. And then he was just like, when is Dwight stopping by? So maybe, maybe here's a. tip. Like, if you're in that situation, maybe don't bring up the TV show. Medical professionals in particular should never bring up your celebrity in an exam room. Well, I think that's fair.
That's just a good, solid boundary. Yeah. You're probably there because you're worried about something or concerned. Yes, that's right. That's right. Yeah. You know what? Tell me in the lobby.
Tell me in the lobby afterwards. You need to be you. Yeah. Right? you need to be who you are and know that that person sees you. Right. You know, I think an analogy that I think of all the time is like I'm an adult person and I pay a mortgage and I'm raising two children and all this stuff. And yet all the time I feel like a little bit of like I can't believe that I am tasked with these adult responsibilities.
Like I can't like young people will look at me and I know that I look like an old person to them. But like inside, I still kind of feel like a flailing 23-year-old who doesn't know what they're doing. So I feel like that's part of it, too. Like when people are approaching me and they're like, oh, my God, I love your body of work and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I still feel like the struggling actor who's trying to make it. Like, that's never left me. I will say, like, before I was on the show, that blog post you wrote to actors. Yeah, that I turned into it.
a book later, yeah. But at that point, I think it was just available. It was just a blog post. Yeah. Advice to actors. It was so, because I'd read that a lot, multiple times before ever meeting you were being on the show. Oh my gosh. I didn't even know that, Zach. Yeah, it was so orienting. I think because a lot of times I think when people can feel the distance between how they're perceived and how, and their interior sense of themselves what you're describing, I think sometimes people's response to that is to try to identify publicly only with the way they're perceived or something. But I remember for you at that time to share the flailing, to share the kind of blemishy, angsty, unsure kind of experience that you'd had was so helpful because it's so
isolating to aspire to some, well, I don't know if that's even true. It's scary to, what am I trying to say? There's a Cherry Jones. You know Cherry Jones the actor, Cherry Jones? She has this quote that I love so much where she says theaters where we comfort each other with our shortcomings, whereas like I'll show you mine and you'll see yours reflected and then we'll have the night of laughs and catharsis and whatever. In a way, like when you wrote that thing, it's like not that that's shortcomings exactly, but I felt comforted by your vulnerability and by your ownership of that vulnerability because I felt so vulnerable. So seeing like, oh, wow, someone who I admire who has like an exciting career and who, you know, is willing to be introspective and revealing in this way. and expose the gap between public perception and interior experience. Like, that for me was really helpful. Sorry, that's such a long-winded answer.
I loved every word of that. No, and I think it's your question, too, which is, like, we were so in awe of Kathy Bates, but, like, maybe Kathy Bates just feels like the same tripping over her own feet actor that we all feel like when we first start a role or first start a job or whatever. But we never asked because we just assumed she must be filled with all. this confidence and all of this, all of it. But that also goes back to you, Zach. You talk about all this anxiety and you're holding these things in Walmart and you can't believe you're on the show.
You were seamlessly a part of our show from the very beginning. Like, it's kind of blowing my mind that you're telling me that you were anxious or that you even were inexperienced because I knew you had done in the loop, but I assumed like there were all these other things too. I had no, I really had no idea that the office was your first television job. And for how just amazing you were, right? So just amazing right out of the gate. And such a smart improviser. I know I'm being an improv nerd here,
but I just love it when people are really smart and say really witty smart things and don't go for the obvious joke and don't go for too much and are understated. And you're all of those things. And I have loved watching your scenes so much. And I love going to the script and reading the script and then watching your scenes because you, I think maybe you and Steve improvise the most. Honestly, if you look at how many episodes you're in and improvise so well, you know. That's very sweet.
I mean, yeah, it's so nice. I started taking acting classes because I would hire in between, like, when we'd be shooting, I would go back to New York and I had this acting coach named Anya. Saffer, who I would go, shout out Tanya Saffer. Because I'd never gone to acting school or anything. So I would go through like scenes from Tennessee Williams place and like take voice classes and do like Alexander technique and all this shit because I was like, I just felt I had such deep imposter syndrome because I hadn't done it before. So it's a, it's nice to hear that it wasn't flagrantly obvious on set.
That's good. This is a great segue for us to ask you if you had ever played A. Blinken other than on the office. I'd been sent an audition for Abe Lincoln Vampire Hunter where I had to learn the Gettysburg Address and I was not hired to be A. Blankin Vampire Hunter. But other than that, I'd never played Abe Lincoln. Wait, so Abe Lincoln recited the Gettysburg Address
while killing a vampires? Or being a vampire. Vampire hunter. I think he hunted the vampires. Oh, he hunted the vampires. But you know how it is with vampires. You start out hunting them and then... You want to be one.
You become one. Yeah. I think they just wanted to see people do the Gettysburg Address to see if they were plodied. as Lincoln, and then they were going to, like, get to the vampire hunting in, like, a later stage of the casting process or something. So I did, for a while, know the Gettysburg dress. Because you had done that prior to playing Abe Lincoln on the office? Yeah, I think so.
I see. Wow. Yeah. So there was a small part of you that had played Abe Lincoln, if not for an audition. I mean, like, my body had played Abe Lincoln in my entire life. I had the doctor, I remember Abe Lincoln had something called Marfan syndrome, which is like this, I guess it's like a congenital. little heart defect or something. I don't know. Basically, like, the symptoms are your wings span is greater than your height. And you have something called a pectus excavatum, I think, which I have.
It's like this weird divot in your chest. I remember going to the doctor and him being like, oh, Abe Lincoln had Marfan syndrome. We're going to screen you for it. And then being just shocked that I didn't have it because I had like all the other. Yeah, I had like all the symptoms of Abe Lincoln's disease, but not the actual diagnosis. Not to brag. Hold your applause. What are some of your favorite scenes or moments from the show? It's funny. I remember hearing some interview with Mark Rylance, the actor where he said, like, when you die, probably like the thing that flashes before your eyes isn't the episodes of the shows, but the experience you had making them. And I think for me, when I think of the show, it's sort of a gauzy feeling of like, I remember lunch a lot.
I remember like hanging out with people, like, in between. between setups and stuff. In terms of scenes, like, I think it took me a while till after I was off the office when I started to be able to really enjoy scenes because I didn't feel like, oh, God, what if I fuck this up, you know? Right, right. You could be an audience member and watch it. Yeah.
And I really liked stuff where I liked getting into fights with Ed Helms. I thought that was fun. I like menacing Ed Helms. I looked online to see what are the fan favorite quotes of Gabe. Oh, really? Yeah. And I share one of them with the internet. So I love so much in search committee when you just start asking him questions about the sun.
And then Andy knows all this information about the sun. And you say, shut up about the sun. Shut up about the sun. So that made it as one of best Gabe quotes. It's also one of mine. Here's another one, walk away bitch. Oh, yeah, that was to Andy, right? Yeah, that's to Andy.
I remember that. And then this is one I forget. got and I actually had to go and rewatch the episode. We haven't gotten to it yet, Jenna. It's from turf war. And Gabe says, sometimes I wonder if I have ovaries in my scrotum because I am great at girl talk. Jesus Christ. That's the most upsetting. Sorry, sorry America. That's the most upsetting phrase I've ever heard. Oh my gosh. And the other one was there are plenty of people who love touching me. Oh, I remember that scene. It's heartbreaking. It's when Kelly hugs Gabe. This episode is brought to you by Square.
You're not just running a restaurant, you're building something big, and Square's there for all of it, giving your customers more ways to order, whether that's in-person with Square kiosk or online. Instant access to your sales, plus the funding you need to go even bigger. And real-time insights, so you know what's working, what's not, what's next. Because when you're doing big things, your tools should to. Visit square.ca to get started. Tim's new scrambled egg loaded croissant. Or is it croissant? No matter how you say it, start your day with freshly cracked scrambled eggs loaded on a buttery, flaky croissant. Try it with
maple brown butter today at Tim's. At participating restaurants in Canada for limited time. It got Willa. It got my daughter. I need to find her. Willa! From acclaimed director of Paul Thomas Sanderson. You can save that girl. On September 26th, experience what is being called the best movie of the year. This is at the end of the line. Not for you. Leonardo DiCaprio, Sean Pan, Benicio del Toro, Tiana Taylor, Chase Infinity.
Let's go! Here I come. One battle after another. Only in theater September 26th. Experience it in IMAX. You can't hide. When we were rewatching search committee. Yeah.
It's Toby. Gabe and Jim are the search committee, and you got to interview all of those amazing, like, actors doing the cameos. Are there any of that stood out to you? I remember Will Arnette would do this thing where he would sort of start improvising. He'd be joking around in this way that was so unbelievably funny in between takes. And then when they would call action, it sort of like just continue in a way. I remember being like, oh, wow, that's fascinating. Like he's kind of in a, it doesn't stop in between cut in action. He's like kind of. Not in a tiring way. You know, there's people who are like on in a way. It wasn't like that. It was just like he was sort of in this. It was like he was keeping it like simmering or something.
I remember being fascinated by that. Yeah. And I remember feeling like immediately like Ray Romano, I just went to like rest my head on his shoulder. He was like so warm and sweet. And I really loved him. And then I also like it was fun. I remember like interviewed people from the office.
Yeah. Which was fun to do like. Your interview of Mindy. as Kelly was really funny. And I think it's in the bloopers because Gabe decides that, oh, maybe I'm going to be the voice of reason here. And he looks at Jim and Toby when Kelly walks in and goes, we don't really need to go through all this, do we? And we're not, we're not, this isn't like a serious interview, right? And they both just throw you under the bus.
And Toby's like, no, I think we, it is serious. And then Gabe says to Kelly, what are your weaknesses? And Kelly goes, I don't have any ass. Something like that. You guys, you could tell that Mindy was like breaking, you know, and just the whole scene is so funny. I imagine there's a lot of great bloopers from that day. Yeah, I mean, and by that point, I guess that was late enough in the shooting process where I felt like my blood pressure had dropped incrementally a little bit and I was able to. It looked like you were having fun.
I remember enjoying those scenes more where I was like, okay, like, I think after they brought me back for another season, I thought like, well, if they were horrified, they wouldn't have done that. And that really put me at ease where I just thought, okay, well, if they've decided they want me here, then it's their funeral. I can't. You know, I'll take it. The other thing when I looked up the character, Gabe, and I did like an image search, one of the first things that comes up is Gabe's Lady Gaga. Yeah. That costume was, oh, my gosh. I just remember you were in hair and makeup for so long. Yeah. You had the eyelashes?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. I've never felt more like myself on set. I think, you know, I never walked in high heels before. I don't know where they found high heels, my size. What's your shoe size? 11 and a half, a modest 11 and a half. You know, but it was, I don't know if you guys know this.
Extremely hard to walk in me. We have an idea. What? Yeah, yeah. I know. No man has ever told you this. It was so hard to move. I couldn't believe it.
I was like, wait, people do this. For hours at a time? It's kind of insane. It's ridiculous when you think about it. It's like I'm going to design a shoe where you're up on your tippy toes. Now go walk all day. Not just that. So many high heels.
They're made for a foot where you just have one long center toe. Yes, true. It's like not even the shape of your foot. Which luckily I do have. That is a long center toe. That was also an Abraham Lincoln. Yes, that's one of the symptoms of our fan syndrome. Just a single long toe.
In terms of volume, it's the same volume as, five toes, but just in one. In the one toe. Yes. Right. Exactly. All right. We have one other question we've been curious about. Great. The Great Danes. You had to work a lot with these giant dogs. Was there anything, like any memory
从体积上来说，它的体积跟五个脚趾一样，但它只有一个，就在这一个脚趾上。是的。对。没错。好了。我们还有另一个一直很好奇的问题。太好了。大丹犬。你们得和这些巨型犬合作很多。有什么像什么样的记忆吗？
from working with those dogs? Yeah, they were like frustratingly professional. Really? Yeah. I was like, you know, their dog, you just want to like rub your face in their snout. You just want to be like, oh, I love you. You're beautiful. You're a miracle. And they were just like, we're working. They just were so full.
跟那些狗合作过吗？对，它们简直专业得让人沮丧。真的吗？对。我就觉得，你知道，它们的狗，你只想把脸埋在它们的鼻口里。你只想说，哦，我爱你。你太美了。你是个奇迹。而它们却觉得，我们在工作。它们太专心了。
They had that, like, working dog thing where they were just, like, not screwing around. Yeah. And I was like, no snuggles. No. I was like, spooned me, great team. And they're like, no, thank you. No, thank you, strange human. I'm working.
它们有一种工作犬的气质，就是那种绝不胡闹的感觉。对。然后我说，没有拥抱吗？没有。我说，抱抱我吧，好团队。它们说，不用了，谢谢。不用了，谢谢，奇怪的人。我在工作。
Yeah. I was like, it truly was like, they were like, like, like, you ever meet like one of those former child stars who's been like working from the time they were three and they're like, where's my light? Okay. I just need a little bit of eyebrow pencil and let's go. You know, those people who are just like, they were like that, but just the canine version. Yeah.
对。我当时就觉得，这真的就像，它们就像，就像，你有没有见过那种前童星，从三岁起就开始工作的那种，它们会说，我的灯光在哪里？好吧。我只需要一点眉笔，我们走吧。你知道那些人，就像那样，只不过是犬类版本。对。
Do you share Gabe's love of horror films? No. I mean, I like some horror movies, but not really. What I do love is I really like wake-up pranks. Do you guys know about wake-up pranks? No. Do you wake up someone in a horrible manner? Yeah, it's like people waking up their friends in mean ways.
你和加布一样喜欢恐怖片吗？不。我是说，我喜欢一些恐怖片，但不是特别喜欢。我真正喜欢的是恶作剧。你们知道恶作剧吗？不知道。你会用一种可怕的方式把某人弄醒吗？对，就像人们用卑鄙的方式把朋友弄醒一样。
Oh, no. And people get scared, and I think it's very funny and very mean. And there's one where they're like, this guy's asleep. I guess they got like fast food. They're in a van. This guy's asleep. He's got like a burger on his lap, but he fell asleep before he ate his burger. and I think there's like a truck with one of those
哦，不。人们会吓一跳，我觉得这非常搞笑，也非常恶劣。有一个视频是这样的，这家伙睡着了。我想他们买了一些快餐。他们在面包车里。这家伙睡着了。他的大腿上放着一个汉堡，但他还没吃汉堡就睡着了。我想有一辆卡车拉着一辆
it's like one of those trucks that pulls cars behind it so it looks like the car is facing Oh yeah like the vehicle You could mistake it as an oncoming vehicle Right, right So this guy's asleep so everyone in the car decides to wake up prank him And what they do is they swerve and scream all at the same time And he wakes up and he sees this car in front of him
就像那种后面拖着汽车的卡车，所以看起来那辆车正对着 哦对，就像那辆车一样 你可能会把它误认为是迎面开来的车 对，对 所以这家伙睡着了，所以车里的每个人都决定整蛊他 他们的做法是同时转向并尖叫 他醒了过来，看到前面有这辆车
And he thinks, you know, this is it And he screams and he just squeezes the hell out of his burger. He just squeezes this burger so hard. And then they show it in slow-mo. It's just like face contorting and I'm squeezing the burger. It's so fun. It's very mean and I don't think it's right, but it is very funny. And then I also like close call videos where it's like I can't stand like fail videos where people get hurt. I can't stand it. But close call videos are the best. Oh, when someone almost falls? Yes. Yes. It's the best. It's the best. Like I haven't seen the videos, but I will tell you, I have a memory I will never forget. I was in the Dallas
他心想，这下完了，然后他大叫一声，死死地捏着他的汉堡。他把这个汉堡捏得死死的。然后他们以慢动作播放出来。简直就像是面部扭曲，而我在捏着汉堡。太搞笑了。这很卑鄙，我也觉得这不对，但确实非常搞笑。然后我还喜欢千钧一发的视频，就是那种，我受不了那种人们受伤的失败视频。我受不了。但千钧一发的视频最棒了。哦，当有人差一点摔倒的时候？对。对。太棒了。太棒了。虽然我没看过那些视频，但我可以告诉你，我有一段永远不会忘记的记忆。我在达拉斯
Fort Worth Airport, and there was this long corridor that we were all walking down, right? And there's a woman coming, kind of swimming upstream against all of us. She was clearly very late for her flight. And she is running. I'm talking a full sprint with like trying to juggle a carry on, but a full sprint. She's in wedge flip-flops, and she is running. And we can see her from so far in this corridor, and she's running, and the front of her flip-flop bends forward under her foot, and then she lurches forward, and then she tries to overcompensate.
沃思堡机场，有一条长长的走廊，我们都在那条走廊里走着，对吧？然后迎面走来一个女人，有点像逆流而上，从我们所有人身边走过。很明显，她赶不上航班了。她在跑。我说的是全速冲刺，手里还试图抛接一个随身行李，全速冲刺。她穿着厚底人字拖，在奔跑。我们从这条走廊很远的地方就能看到她，她在奔跑，她人字拖的前端在脚下向前弯曲，然后她向前踉跄，接着她试图过度代偿。
She lurches back. And she did it for probably. It felt like 10 minutes. He was like, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. And we were all so invested. It was like, I don't know, 80 strangers, and we're like, is she going down? What do we do? And then she, right before she face planted, she pulled herself up.
她往后踉跄。她可能持续了这么久。感觉就像10分钟。他就像，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。我们所有人都极其投入。大概有80个陌生人，我们在想，她要摔倒了吗？我们该怎么办？然后，就在她脸朝下摔倒之前，她把自己拉了起来。
Yeah. And we were all like, oh, and then she ran past us. I'll never forget it. Oh, my God. I've seen videos. If you've seen the videos of someone who's, like, slipping on ice, but for, like, a very long time. It's like that.
对。我们都发出哦的一声，然后她从我们身边跑过。我永远不会忘记。哦，天哪。我看过视频。如果你看过那种在冰上滑倒，但持续时间非常长的视频。就像那样。
It's like that. Yes. Like, that's what it feels like to be. person is to be just like a prolonged ice slip that seems to never stop. And when it turns out good, right? Yes. I'm so relieved. But there's so many and you can watch them to compilations. It's like people like their kid almost like is riding a bike and almost runs into something and they swoop in and grab them or it's like it's just like humans evading disaster is like the best. Have you seen the videos of people who they're scaring someone? Yes. But they're doing it by pretending
就像那样。对。作为一个人的感觉，就像是一次似乎永远不会停止的漫长的滑冰。而且结果还不错，对吧？是的。我太欣慰了。但有太多这样的视频了，你可以看它们的合集。就像人们看到他们的孩子差点骑着自行车撞到什么东西，然后他们冲过去抓住他们，或者说这就像人类躲避灾难一样是最棒的。你看过那些把人吓一跳的视频吗？对。但他们的做法是假装
that they're scared of something themselves. Yes, and then the other person runs away. Yes. They're brilliant. So, like, there's like a woman and she's, like, taking out the trash with her husband, and she opens up the trash can and that she's like, and then he loses, he hasn't even seen anything. And it's just like the fighter flight response.
他们自己对什么东西感到害怕。对，然后另一个人跑开。对。它们太绝了。所以，就像有个女人和她丈夫一起去倒垃圾，她打开垃圾桶，然后她就像，接着他吓坏了，他甚至什么都没看到。这就像是战斗或逃跑反应。
But it's so, but the psychology behind it to me is so interesting because it's like, it's like, I share fear with you. Yeah. We share that. But the one person, it's just. just pretending and then the other person. I know. It's really fascinating.
但这太，其背后的心理对我来说非常有趣，因为这就好像，我与你分享恐惧。对。我们分享那种恐惧。但其中一个人只是在假装，而另一个人。我知道。这真的很吸引人。
I kind of want to try it out. You should try it. It's a cheap prank. All you have to do is act scared. There's one more. I have to say, because these are now fascinating me. You might like it. So there's the other one where you're in a group, like with your family.
我有点想试试。你应该试试。这是一个低成本的恶作剧。你只需要装作害怕。还有一个。我必须说，因为这些现在让我着迷。你可能会喜欢。所以还有另一个，你在一个群体里，比如和你的家人一起。
And you pick someone and you say, like, I learned, we're going to do a magic trick. I'm making you visible. And you put a sheet over them and then you, like, say some magic words. And then you pull the sheet. off and everyone in the room has agreed to pretend that the person is invisible. Oh, that's amazing. It's always the mom. They always do it to the mom, right?
你挑一个人说，我学到了，我们要玩一个魔术。我让你隐形。你给他们盖上一张床单，然后你念一些魔术咒语。接着你把床单拉开，房间里的所有人都同意假装那个人是隐形的。哦，太神奇了。总是妈妈。他们总是对妈妈这么做，对吧？
And then, so then they pull the sheet off. And then everyone's like, no way. Holy, oh, my God. And then the person's like, what, oh, my God, what, what, what? You can't, I don't get it. That's amazing. It's crazy. It's crazy.
然后，他们把床单拉开。接着每个人都说，不会吧。天哪，哦，天哪。然后那个人说，什么，哦，天哪，什么，什么，什么？你不能，我不明白。太神奇了。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。
It's the mom, like, an invisible mom. I feel like so many moms in family dynamics are just the invisible caretaker of everyone. They're already invisible. It's like that. That S&L sketch at Christmas, everyone's saying, I got a piano. And the mom goes, and I got a robe. And that's all she got. And it's like over and over.
就像是妈妈，一个隐形的妈妈。我觉得家庭动态中的许多妈妈都只是每个人的隐形照顾者。她们已经隐形了。就像圣诞节的那个周六夜现场小品，每个人都说，我得到了一架钢琴。妈妈说，我得到了一件长袍。这就是她得到的一切。而且是一次又一次。
But then I got a car. I got a robe. Also, at the end, they're like, wait a second. What's this secret pile of presents? And the mom's like, oh. And they're like, it's presents for the dog. And then the dog gets a robe as well. I think I'm going to watch the one of, particularly the one where they're scared,
但后来我得到了一辆车。我得到了一长袍。还有，在最后，他们说，等一下。这个秘密礼物堆是什么？妈妈说，哦。他们说，这是给狗的礼物。然后狗也得到了一件长袍。我想我要去看那个，特别是他们被吓到的那个，
Were they act scared? Yes, it's very fun. I cannot wait. It's so interesting. It's so interesting that people, like, share fear. It's fascinating. I heard that, I don't even know if this is true. This could just be something like I am basically making up.
它们看起来害怕吗？是的，太有趣了。我迫不及待。这太有意思了。人们会分享恐惧，这真的很迷人。我听说过这个，我甚至不知道这是否是真的。这可能只是我随便编造的。
But that, like, laughter, like the origins of laughter is it was like a way that, like, monkeys could tell each other that a perceived danger was no longer a threat. Like, so basically it's like, okay, we're a bunch of monkeys. Like, we think we see a tiger. Everyone gets tense. And then I realized, oh, it's not a tiger. It's something that looked like a tiger, but it isn't a tiger. Then we all laugh, and it's a way of quickly dispersing the information that, like, what seemed to be threatening is, in fact, not a threat.
但这种笑，笑的起源其实是猴子用来告诉彼此某个察觉到的危险不再是威胁的一种方式。所以基本上就是，好吧，我们是一群猴子。比如，我们以为看到了一只老虎。每个人都很紧张。然后我意识到，哦，这不是老虎。它看起来像老虎，但并不是老虎。然后我们都笑了，这是一种快速传播信息的方式，表明看起来具有威胁的东西实际上并非威胁。
So it's like this rolling sound that, like, lets everyone know. It's like a fire drill in reverse. It makes so much sense. Right. And then also it makes so much sense why comedy is something we're drawn to watch and that, like, soothes us, you know? Oh, that's interesting. Yes.
所以这就像是一个滚动的声音，让每个人都知道。这就像是一个反向的消防演习。太有道理了。对。然后这也解释了为什么我们会被喜剧吸引并从中获得慰藉，对吧？哦，这很有趣。是的。
Yes. I mean, like, I remember when I injured my baby, back when I broke my back and I watched the Larry Sanders show. Me and Creed and Jenna one night in her hotel room. Binged the Larry Sanders show. And like that laughter, like it brings you relief. Yeah. Right? And maybe it goes all the way back to that. Just bunch of monkeys. Releasing some. There's no tiger. Yeah. Yeah. That's our whole show is just I'm very scared of what Michael Scott is going to say or do right now. Okay. All right. All right. I think that's right. It's like tension, cringe release, you know, set up, tension, punchline.
对。我是说，就像我记得我弄伤背部、脊椎骨折的时候，我看了《拉里·桑德斯秀》。有一天晚上，我和克里德还有珍娜在她的酒店房间里。狂刷了《拉里·桑德斯秀》。这种笑声会带给你解脱。对吧？也许这可以追溯到很久以前。只是一群猴子。释放一些压力。没有老虎。对。对。我们的整个节目就是——我很害怕迈克尔·斯科特现在会说些什么或做些什么。好吧。好吧。好吧。我想那是对的。就像是紧张、尴尬、释放，你知道的，铺垫、紧张、笑点。
Like, yeah, I don't know. Again, that could be total malarkey, but I, I mean, it tracks. I've been really into, there's a show about animals on Netflix and we watch the one about dogs. It's so good. Yeah. And dogs do this little sniffy, snorty thing when they're, you know how they play fight? And it's to let the other dog know that I'm not serious.
比如，我不知道。再说一次，这可能是胡扯，但我觉得，这说得通。我最近迷上了一个在Netflix上关于动物的节目，我们看了狗的那集。太棒了。对。当狗在假装打闹时，它们会发出这种小小的嗅鼻子、哼鼻子的声音，你知道吗？这是为了让另一只狗知道我不是认真的。
And they, so if you hear your dog and now my little two Chihuahua rescues when they play, I hear it. They go, shh, really? And it's like, it's like, I'm, I'm just having fun. That must be so hard on dogs who, like, want to be aggressive but have allergies where they're, like, trying to, like, really, like, big dog and other dog. And they're just like, yeah, like a pug. Like, a pug can never be taken seriously when he's trying to, like, be aggressive.
所以如果你听到你的狗——现在我那两只吉娃娃救援犬在玩耍时，我能听到。它们会发出‘嘘’的声音，真的吗？这就像是，我只是在玩。对于那些想表现得有攻击性但又过敏的狗来说，这一定很难吧，它们试图表现得像只大狗，对另一只狗那样。而它们就像是，对，就像哈巴狗。哈巴狗在试图表现得有攻击性时，永远不会被当真。
Like, I'm actually angry. I really mean it, guys. Like, no, you don't. No, you don't. You're being silly. That's funny. Do you get recognized as Gabe? Sometimes.
就像，我真的很生气。我是认真的，伙计们。就像，不，你不是。不，你不是。你在耍宝。这太搞笑了。你会被认出是加布（Gabe）吗？有时候。
Yeah. It happens sometimes. And what is that like? I had a really bad one recently because I saw it. So I'm making the show now this like stop motion show. And in it there's a like a lactation station, you know, that they have at the airport. And we were getting designs for them. And I was like, oh, I want something really simple.
对。有时候会发生。那是什么感觉？我最近遇到了一次很糟糕的经历，因为我看到了。我正在制作这个节目，一个定格动画节目。里面有一个哺乳室，你知道机场里有的那种。我们正在获取它们的设计。我就想，哦，我想要一些非常简单的东西。
And I was in an airport. There was an empty lactation station. And I wanted to send a picture to the production designer to be like, this is what we're going for. This is perfect example, right? So I started to take a picture of the lactation station as someone came up to me and was like, hey, man, you were Gabe on the office. No, it's not lost on me that Gabe is, in many ways, quite a creepy character. And so this guy just saw me by myself in an airport photographing a lactation station like a true predator from hell.
当时我在机场。有一个空着的哺乳室。我想给布景设计师发张照片，意思是：这就是我们想要的风格。这是个完美的例子，对吧？所以我开始给哺乳室拍照，这时有人朝我走过来，说：‘嘿，兄弟，你是在《办公室》里演加布的那个人吗？’我不禁想到，加布在很多方面都是一个相当诡异的角色。所以这家伙看到我独自一人在机场像个来自地狱的真正掠夺者一样拍摄哺乳室。
I mean, like that's an insane thing to do, right, to take a picture. Like, from, he has no context. And if I say, this is for a show, that sounds even worse. It's like, it's for a show, really, buddy? And so that was a truly mortifying where I'm like, he must think I'm like that Gabe is like a toned down version of me based on that experience. But yeah, people sometimes will recognize me from the show. So after the office, you did Silicon Valley. You've done all these other things.
我的意思是，拍照是一件很疯狂的事，对吧？他没有任何背景。如果我说，这是为了一个节目，听起来甚至更糟。就像是‘这是为了一个节目，真的吗，老兄？’所以那真是羞辱到家了，我想他一定觉得加布其实是我本色出演的温和版。不过是的，人们有时会从节目中认出我。所以在《办公室》之后，你演了《硅谷》。你还演了所有这些其他的作品。
Do you still get approached more for being on the office or for other roles or is it pretty 50-50? I'd say it's like probably 50-50 with the office and then everything else I've ever done. So it's like the single thing maybe more, well, I don't know. Silicon Valley, yeah, it's probably like around 50, 50. It depends. It's like demographically specific. Yeah. You know?
大家找你是因为《办公室》更多，还是因为其他角色更多，或者基本上是各占一半？我会说大概一半是《办公室》，另一半是我演过的所有其他作品。所以这可能是单一作品占比最多的，嗯，我不知道。《硅谷》也是，大概也是一半一半吧。这取决于具体情况。这跟人口统计数据有关。对。你知道的吗？
And it's interesting. Like if it's younger people, it's probably the office. If it's like really young people, I think it's so sweet to me that kids find it so comforting that it's a kind of emotional wallpaper. Like people have watched it a million times will turn it on as a way of feeling like they're kind of among their friends or in a kind of soothing, warm, silly, environment. I think it's so sweet. And so it's like nice when it's like some, you know, whatever, 19-year-old who's immersed in the Scranton paper industry, fictional world. I think that's so
这很有趣。如果是年轻人，可能看过《办公室》。如果是非常年轻的人，我觉得孩子们觉得这很慰藉，这让我觉得非常暖心，它就像是一种情感壁纸。人们看过无数遍，把它当作一种背景，让他们觉得自己仿佛置身于朋友之中，或者身处某种抚慰人心、温暖、傻气的环境中。我觉得这太甜了。所以当某个十九岁、沉浸在斯克兰顿纸业公司虚构世界里的人认出你时，那种感觉真的很美好。我觉得这太
sweet. I like that. Have you rewatched the show? Some of it. I hate watching anything I'm in, so not that stuff. But I'd already watched the show so much when I came up. I think I would rewatch the show a lot before I was on the show. But I haven't done like the wall-to-wall re-watch. We hadn't either. This is the first time for us. I'd seen episodes here and there. We've talked about that. But this is really our first time to see some of these episodes in a long time since they aired. Does it feel like, does watching the show feel like you're looking at a photo album of your friends and your life in a way? Or does it feel like you can sort of suspend disbelief and get lost in the story of the show? Are you able to invest in the fictional reality of the show when you're watching it? I think so. Because of the passage of time, It's both things. So I have a lot of nostalgic thoughts and feelings.
美妙了。我喜欢这样。你重温过这部剧吗？看过一部分。我讨厌看任何有我出镜的东西，所以那些部分就算了。但在我参演之前，其实我已经看了很多遍这部剧。我想在参演之前我就会经常重温这部剧。但我并没有像那种从头到尾的疯狂重温。我们也没有。这对我们来说是第一次。我零星看过一些剧集。我们讨论过这个。但对我们来说，这真的是自播出以来这么长时间内第一次看到其中一些剧集。看这部剧的感觉，是不是就像在翻看朋友和生活的老照片相册？还是说你可以某种程度上暂停怀疑，迷失在节目的故事中？你在观看时能投入到节目的虚构现实中吗？我想是的。因为时间的流逝，这两种感觉都有。所以我有很多怀旧的想法和感受。
I get really sentimental when I'm watching it. I remember parts of my life that were happening when we were making those episodes. I miss people when I watch it. But I can also, when I watch it, what's weird is I have images of all the things you can't see in the episodes. So, like, I can feel Brian Whittle holding his boom above my desk in a scene when I'm watching. the rewatch. You know, I can like feel where, oh, that video village was over in the conference room for this one and Kelly's shouting out some safety meeting. So it's like all of the behind the camera stuff pops into my head as well. But then at the same time, I have found myself
看的时候我会变得多愁善感。我想起拍摄那些剧集时我生活中正在发生的事情。看的时候我很想念大家。但与此同时，当我观看时，奇怪的是，我有那些你在剧集中看不到的东西的画面。所以，比如，在重看时，我能感觉到布莱恩·惠特尔（Brian Whittle）在我的办公桌上方举着他的吊杆麦克风。你知道的，我能感觉到，哦，当时那场戏的视频村（监视器区域）在会议室那边，凯利在外面大声喊着什么安全会议。所以所有摄像机背后的东西都会涌入我的脑海。但与此同时，我发现自己
getting invested in the characters. Like, I personally feel that Aaron is not the one for Andy. Not at all. I am getting angry. It's being shoved down my throat, that I'm being told that they're the perfect couple, when I actually feel like Andy is thriving with his current girlfriend. Jessica. Jessica is great. I like Jessica. Yeah. You know?
开始对角色投入感情。比如，我个人觉得艾琳（Erin）并不是安迪（Andy）的真命天女。一点也不。我很生气。这种观点被硬塞给我，他们告诉我这是绝配，而实际上我觉得安迪和他的现任女友在一起时发展得很好。杰西卡（Jessica）。杰西卡很好。我喜欢杰西卡。对。你知道吗？
So I don't know. So I do, I have like some fan reactions when I watch the show as well. What about you, Ange? Oh, I mean, I think you said that so well. That's exactly how I feel. It's both for me. It's a photo album and I'm in the audience and I kind of switch back and forth. I have really strong memories of.
所以，我不知道。所以，看剧的时候我也会有一些粉丝般的反应。你呢，安吉？哦，我是说，你表达得太好了。这正是我所感到的。对我来说两者皆有。这既是一本相册，而我又坐在观众席上，我会在两者之间来回切换。我对那些
episodes, you know, when things were happening in my life. And I watch it with that layer. Wow. So it's not even just the environment of the set, but it's the environment of your life at that time. That's fascinating. It was, what, nine years of our life and, you know, babies were born and family members passed away. And so a lot of life happens in nine years. And I just watched that play out through this other filter of being a character. It's kind of, it's really surreal. That's trippy, yeah. A friend of mine said to me, I was like talking about some, maybe New York or something,
剧集有着非常深刻的记忆，你知道的，当时我生活中正在发生一些事情。我带着这一层滤镜去观看。哇。所以这不仅是片场的环境，也是你当时生活的环境。这太迷人了。那是我们生命中的九年，你知道的，孩子们出生了，家人们相继离世。所以九年里发生了太多的生活琐事。我只是通过扮演角色的另一层滤镜看着这一切上演。这感觉真有点超现实。太魔幻了，是的。我的一个朋友对我说，我当时在谈论一些事情，也许是纽约什么的，
and she goes, well, places aren't places as much as there are times. Like when you think of a place, often you're thinking of a time. Yeah. And so it's not necessarily the geography of the place, but it's the sort of psychic place you were in in your life, right? Like what was happening or who you were at that time. So it's so interesting that it's the show where you're being somebody different. Like you're playing a different person, but also you were a different person in
她说，地方与其说是地方，不如说是时间。就像当你想起一个地方时，通常你想到的是一个时间。对。所以它不一定指那个地方的地理位置，而是你当时在生活中心理上所处的状态，对吧？比如当时发生了什么，或者那时你是谁。所以很有趣的是，在这个节目里你扮演的是别人。就像你在扮演一个不同的人，但同时你在
your life at that time, right? Like the circumstances of your life were different, your relationships were different, everything was different. Can I just like one more? I'm just like, for you guys, if there's something like you guys could go back and tell yourselves, like, in that Our Town style, like, what would you, like, if you could go back to like season one and visit with you, like, as your own, like, fairy godmother or ghost of Christmas future or whatever, like, what would you say?
当时的生活中也是一个不同的人，对吧？你生活的环境不同了，你的人际关系不同了，一切都不同了。我能再问一个吗？我就想问，对你们来说，如果有什么事是你们可以回到过去告诉自己的，就像那种《小镇风云》式的风格，比如，你们会……如果你们能回到第一季，以你们自己的仙女教母或未来之灵之类的身份去探望当时的自己，你会说些什么？
Or maybe that's too hard a question. Hmm. I would say, I think there are a lot of ways that I know how to. advocate for myself professionally now that I had to really learn on the go. And I feel like in some cases, I even got like some bad advice. You know, there were ways where like as you're kind of an up-and-coming actor and maybe you're suddenly on this hit show, there are a lot of people that have ideas for you professionally. And I was just happy being on the office. I didn't need an and. I didn't need to also have a product line or also be a movie star. And yet I felt the energy coming at
或者说这个问题太难了。嗯。我会说，我觉得现在我有很多方法在职业上为自己争取权益，这些都是我必须在实践中真正去学习的。而且我觉得在某些情况下，我甚至还得到了一些糟糕的建议。你知道，有时候当你作为一个崭露头角的演员，可能突然出现在一部大热剧里，会有很多人对你的职业生涯指手画脚。而我当时在《办公室》里就很开心了。我不需要“而且”。我不需要既有产品线，又要当电影明星。然而我却感受到扑面而来的压力，
me telling me I needed to do all this more. And I think in some ways, you know, I would do the TV show and then I would spend my hiatus doing all the more that everyone was telling me that I wanted and that I had to do and that this is what you do next. And the truth is, is I just wanted to spend my hiatus traveling and enjoying my life and being in love. And sometimes I look back on that time and I think, wow, I was just too busy doing a bunch of things that I felt like were expected of me. But my truth was, I just want to be on this TV show. I love it. I'm happy. This is enough. And it took me a really long time to get to a place where I didn't let other people's idea of what my life should be. I figured out what my ambition is in life, but I spent
告诉我必须要做更多的事情。我觉得在某种程度上，你知道，我会拍电视剧，然后我会把整个假期都用来做所有那些大家告诉我我想要、我必须去做、以及接下来就该做的事情。但事实是，我只想要把假期花在旅行、享受生活和谈恋爱上。有时我回想起那段时光，心想，哇，我当时只是忙着去做一堆我觉得别人对我的期望的事情。但我的真实想法是，我只想拍这部电视剧。我喜欢它。我很开心。这就足够了。我花了很长的时间才走到这一步，不再受制于别人对我的生活应该是什么样子的想法。我弄清楚了自己的人生野心是什么，但我花了好多年。
a lot of years. I don't know. I mean, I don't necessarily regret any of those movies or any of those experiences or any of those things. But I think it's a life lesson coming to a place where you're like, well, what's enough for me is okay. Yes, that's right. I don't have to want or need things other people need. What I need is enough. And that's Okay. Yeah. And I think it's even still shocking to people when I say, no, the podcast is enough. I enjoy this. I like concentrating on it. I like this being my one thing. I think maybe that's me. Maybe I'm like a monogamous worker. Like I have a job I like to do and that's the job I like to do and fully and I enjoy it. And then I like to put it away. Like I don't need a lot of ands. I don't. So. That's a great. I wish I could have told myself to trust that more in me. It's so noisy probably when you, right?
我不知道。我是说，我并不一定后悔拍过的任何电影、经历过的任何事情。但我觉得这是一个人生的教训，当你意识到“对我来说足够了这就很好”时，那就是成长。是的，没错。我不必去渴望或需要别人需要的东西。我所需要的就足够了。这就行了。是的。而且我觉得当我说“不，这个播客就够了。我很享受这个。我喜欢专注于它。我喜欢这是我唯一在做的事”时，人们依然会感到震惊。我想这可能就是我吧。也许我是一个工作上的“一夫一妻制者”？就像我有一份喜欢的工作，那就是我喜欢做的工作，我要全身心投入并乐在其中。然后我喜欢把它收起来。我是说我不需要很多“而且”。我不需要。所以。这是一个很棒的。我希望我以前能告诉自己更相信内心这种想法。当你在其中的时候，周围的声音可能太嘈杂了，对吧？
Like if all of a sudden you're on the show and it's a success and it's the cacophony of that and all of the, and all the projection that it cooks up and everything. I think they get. There's a lot of like fear-based sort of communication and that too, which is like, well, listen, if you don't do this now, it's not going to be there later. No one's going to want you later if you don't do this now. Right. Or you won't work later if you're not working now.
就像如果你突然上了一部剧，它成功了，那是各种声音的杂乱交织，所有的喧嚣，以及它所带来的一切投射和种种情绪。我觉得他们开始。这其中也有很多基于恐惧的交流，大概就是，听着，如果你现在不这样做，以后就没有了。如果你现在不这样做，以后没有人会想要你。对吧。或者如果你现在不工作，以后就没工作可做了。
or any of it, you know, and so you're like, oh, yeah, oh, yeah, I don't, I don't want this to go away. So it's very, it can be kind of confusing what to do with that. And then, of course, I had spent 10 years not working at all. So you're like, yeah, yeah, I don't want, I mean, I don't want to go back to that, I guess. So I don't know. Yeah. I think for me, I would look back and just tell myself, I'm going to be just fine. I think I was just worried that I wasn't going to be everything I was thought I should be
或者诸如此类的话，你知道，所以你会想，哦，对啊，哦，对啊，我可不想，我不想让这一切消失。所以怎么处理这种状况真的会让人感到很困惑。而且，当然，我之前有十年完全没有工作。所以你会想，对啊，对啊，我不想，我是说，我可不想回到那种日子，我想是的。所以我不知道。是的。我想对我来说，我会回过头来告诉自己，我一切都会好起来的。我想我只是担心自己无法成为别人认为我应该成为的一切，
and that I don't need to be anything other than just okay with myself. That's what I think. It's interesting how similar, like success on somebody else's terms is not success. And success on your own terms doesn't have to look like somebody else's or like the sort of consensus aspiration, right? It's like you're, and to be like, I'm enough, basically I'm enough, who I am is enough, what I want is enough. I think that, and that was something in that blog post that made an impression on me when I read it too,
而且我不需要成为别的什么，只需要悦纳自己就行了。这就是我的想法。有趣的是，按照别人的标准取得的成功根本不算成功。而按你自己的标准取得的成功，不必看起来像别人的标准，也不必符合那种大众共识的渴望，对吧？这就好比你，坚信“我足够了”，基本上就是“我足够了，我是谁就足够了，我想要什么就足够了”。我觉得，那也是我读到那篇博客文章时给我留下深刻印象的东西，
which is I think I don't remember the exact phrasing of it. It was basically like, don't postpone joy. Don't make a certain kind of professional success a prerequisite for participating in your own life. That's my recollection. Yeah. Well, that was a thing when you're a struggling actor, especially, you're like, well, I can't go to my friend's wedding because I might get a callback for a thing that I auditioned for. so I need to be here or whatever it is.
那就是——我记不清具体措辞了。基本上就是：不要推迟快乐。不要把某种特定的职业成功当作参与自己生活的先决条件。我是这么记的。是的。嗯，那曾是一种常态，特别是当你是一个苦苦挣扎的演员时，你会想，好吧，我不能去参加朋友的婚礼，因为我可能会接到我试镜的那个角色的复试电话，所以我得留在这里，或者诸如此类的事情。
It's like, well, I don't want to have a boyfriend because I don't want to be distracted. There's like all these limits and all these superstitions that you have as an artist because you are holding the art as the only thing, the only aspiration. And so what I found was, oh my gosh, the material and characters that I saw at that wedding and the life experience I got from going to that thing is just going to feed my art. So it's like you can't do art if you're just doing art. I think you have to have a whole life in order to feed it. And an identity that's like where your self-esteem is a little bit more like diversified.
这就好像，嗯，我不想交男朋友，因为我不想分心。作为艺术家，你会有各种各样的限制和迷信，因为你把艺术当作唯一的事情、唯一的追求。所以我发现的是，天啊，我在那场婚礼上看到的素材和人物，以及我从那次经历中获得的人生阅历，都将成为我艺术的养分。所以这就好像如果你只专注于艺术，你就无法真正创作艺术。我觉得你必须拥有丰满的生活来滋养它。还要有一种自尊稍微多元化一点的身份。
And others, if your whole worth originates from your ability to do this one thing and you're not doing that one thing, then you're kind of a ghost. Yeah, exactly. So like to have like, if you're like, oh yeah, I'm not just an actor, I'm someone's mom or I'm someone's, you know, or I'm, or not someone's, I am a mom. I am a bicycle enthusiast. I am a whatever, a volunteer. You know, then it's not like, oh, when I'm auditioning for a part, I'm auditioning for my self-worth. It's like, I'm just auditioning for the part.
反之，如果你的全部价值都源于你做好这一件事的能力，而你偏偏又没在做那件事，那么你基本上就像个幽灵。对啊，完全如此。所以如果能这样想：哦，对啊，我不只是个演员，我是某人的妈妈，我是某人的，你知道，或者不是某人的，我是一位妈妈。我是一个自行车爱好者。我是一个什么样的人，一个志愿者。你知道，这样的话，就不是说“哦，当我为角色试镜时，我是在为我的自我价值试镜”。而是变成“我只是在为这个角色试镜”。
It's like, yeah, which is hard enough or daunting enough. That makes sense. That's beautiful. What about you, Zach? What would you go back and tell yourself? Get a basket at Walmart. If you're going to be carrying that many humidifiers, I was basically like a walking close call video.
就像，是的，这已经够难、够让人畏惧的了。这就对了。太美妙了。你呢，扎克？你会回去对你自己说些什么？去沃尔玛拿个购物篮吧。如果你要搬那么多加湿器的话。我当时简直就像个行走的“千钧一发”视频。
I think what did I tell myself? is something similar it's like it's an interesting I don't know let me think for a second I think I think I probably would try to tell myself and I probably wouldn't be able to hear it
我想，我会对自己说什么呢？是类似的话，这是一个有趣的，我不知道，让我想一秒钟。我想，我想我大概会试图告诉自己，虽然我可能当时根本听不进去，
but like you don't need so much fear to protect you you know what I mean like I think I used anxiety as a kind of as a motivator and as a kind of protection where I sort of felt like well if I'm buying enough humidifiers and running my lines enough times and freaking out enough then surely
但就像，你不需要那么多的恐惧来保护你，你知道我的意思吗？就像我觉得我把焦虑当作一种动力和一种保护，我当时隐约觉得，嗯，如果我买足够的加湿器，把台词背够足够多的次数，焦虑得足够厉害，那么毫无疑问，
I'm doing everything in my power to do a good job. And if I don't do that, then I'm going to be kind of culpable if it doesn't go well. I think if I could go back and say, like, when you're doing all of that, it has more to do with, like, it's more neurotic than artistic. You know what I mean? That actually isn't serving. It's not really, hopefully it doesn't hurt the character or the work, but it's about something different. That's more about, like, your childhood than it is about the job you're doing. You know what I mean?
我就是在尽我所能地把工作做好。如果我不这样做，那么如果事情进展不顺利，我就会负有某种责任。我想如果我能回去说，当你做所有这些事情时，这更多与，就像，神经质有关，而不是艺术创作。你知道我的意思吗？那其实并没有什么用。它并没有真正，希望它不会伤害角色或作品，但它是关于别的事情的。那更多是关于你的童年，而不是你正在做的工作。你知道我的意思吗？
And so I think if I could be like, don't mistake your neuroses for your artistic process. Like develop an artistic process independent of that as much as possible so that you're not just reenacting your own like cuckoo bird story again and again at work. Like tell a new story at work. Tell someone else's story at work. You know what I mean? I think you did hear it because I think just the fact that you recognize it that even though, I mean, it took a minute. It took a many minutes. What was your second question? Oh, yes. Second question is like, did you have a moment where you felt that kind of like...
所以我想如果我能说：不要把你的神经质误认为是你的艺术创作过程。尽可能独立于它培养一种艺术创作过程，这样你就不会只是在工作中一遍又一遍地重演你自己的那些疯狂故事。在工作中讲一个新故事。在工作中讲别人的故事。你知道我的意思吗？我想你确实听进去了，因为仅仅是你认出了这一点这一事实，尽管，我是说，这花了一点时间。这花了好长时间。你的第二个问题是什么？哦，对。第二个问题是，你有没有过这样一个时刻，你感受到了那种……
Because so often, I think when you get the thing that you want, it doesn't feel the way you thought it'd feel, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Like the behind the music kind of, like, thing. Was there a moment, though, where you had that kind of like shimmering magic feeling, like where you were, like, looked around and you were like, oh my God, like that moment where you're just like the sort of the gift of it where you felt like really wholly present in it and able to just enjoy it?
因为很多时候，我觉得当你得到了你想要的东西时，它的感觉并不像你想象的那样，巴拉巴拉巴拉。就像那种“音乐背后”（Behind the Music）式的访谈一样。不过，有没有那么一个时刻，你有那种波光粼粼的魔法般的感觉，就像你环顾四周，心想，天哪，就像那种能感受到它所馈赠的礼物的时刻，让你觉得完全身处其中，并且能够尽情享受？
Like, do you remember either the first or the most intense version of that for you guys? The first one for me was when we were shooting the pilot on the first day, and our director, Ken Kwapis, said, I want to do 30 minutes of all of you all just working in this space. Do your job, and we're just going to come around and silently document you.
比如，你们还记得对你们来说第一次或者最强烈的那种感觉是什么时候吗？对我来说，第一次是在我们拍摄试播集的第一天，我们的导演肯·夸皮斯（Ken Kwapis）说，我想让你们所有人花30分钟在这个空间里工作。做好你们的工作，我们会在一旁默默地记录下来。
Like a documentary, we're going to set the tone of this show. All right, go ahead. And I will never forget that 30 minutes of, first of all, there was silence because nobody really knew what to do. And then I feel like it was Phyllis, picked up her phone and, like, hit some buttons
就像拍纪录片一样，我们要定下这部剧的基调。好了，开始吧。我永远不会忘记那30分钟，首先，现场一片寂静，因为没有人真正知道该做什么。然后我觉得好像是菲莉丝，拿起了她的电话，按了几个按钮，
and started a fake phone call. And then I started to hear buttons over the partition and accounting. And then everybody just started being their character. Oh. And pretending like we worked at a paper company like all together. And I was like, the theater nerd in me was delighted.
开始了一场假电话。接着我开始听到隔板那边会计部门传来的按键声。然后大家就开始扮演各自的角色。哦。假装我们在一家纸业公司一起工作。然后我就觉得，我体内的那个戏剧迷简直乐坏了。
And I thought I'm a part of something very special and I don't know what's going to happen from here. But this is pretty dang cool. Wow. The sound. It just sounds like an orchestra tuning up right before. Like, here we go. We're about to play. Like, wow, that's so exciting.
我想，我正在参与一件非常特别的事情，我不知道接下来会发生什么。但这真的是酷毙了。哇。那个声音。听起来就像管弦乐队在演奏前的调音，就像：好了，我们要开始了。我们要演奏了。哇，太令人兴奋了。
I really felt that. Yeah. I mean, yeah, I loved that so much. For me, there's so many moments that felt like that. And they were almost always in the conference room because we were all in there together. And we were all each other's background. We were all in the moment. And so many times I would have a minute where I was in the scene, but then I would step out of my body.
我真的深有同感。是的。我是说，是的，我太喜欢那个时刻了。对我来说，有很多瞬间都有这种感觉。而且它们几乎总是发生在会议室里，因为我们都在那里。我们都是彼此的背景。我们都融入了那个时刻。很多时候，我会有那么一分钟，我明明在场景中，但我的灵魂却出窍了，
and I would just watch these amazing actors just fire off all these lines and everyone had their own character backstory. And I just would be there in awe being like, this is so cool. This is so cool. And I get to do this. And there were times my character didn't even have lines, but I just couldn't believe I was in the moment. There was a scene where Michael Scott is brainstorming animal hybrids. And no one is saying anything. And Steve, had his scripted lines, but then he started to just, they just let the camera roll and he just kept improvising animal hybrids. And we all just had to sit there and look at him where he was like, head of an owl, body of a walrus, like whatever it was he was saying. And we were just all
我只是看着这些优秀的演员们飙着这些台词，每个人都有自己的角色背景故事。我当时就坐在那里惊叹不已，心想：这太酷了。这太酷了。而我居然能做这个。有时候我的角色甚至没有台词，但我就是不敢相信我正身处其中。有场戏是迈克尔·斯科特在集思广益各种动物杂交种。没有人说话。史蒂夫有他的剧本台词，但他开始，他们只是让摄像机继续拍，他就不停地即兴发挥各种动物杂交种。而我们都只能坐在那里看着他，他说着什么猫头鹰的头、海象的身体，无论他说的是什么。我们大家都在
patiently looking at him. And then one by one, people started to file out like they were over it. And I just remember being like, this is one of, this is the coolest. Like, this is the coolest. And I can't believe I get to do it. It's so sweet that in both your cases, it's sort of like, it's not the kind of grand slam scene for your character. It's just the scene where you're able to kind of, like, behold the majesty of this working situation, right? Where you're like, it's about watching it and participating, but not in a way that foregrounds
耐心地看着他。然后一个接一个，大家开始排队离开，就好像他们受够了似的。我只记得当时心想：这是，这是最酷的。就像，这是最酷的。我简直不敢相信我有机会参与其中。真暖心，对你们俩来说，这都不是那种属于你角色的高光大爆发戏份。而只是那种让你能够去见证这种工作氛围的宏大与美妙的场景，对吧？就像你觉得，这关乎观看和参与，但又不是那种把聚光灯聚焦在
you. It's just a, I think, like, being a small part of a big thing is, like, the best feeling ever, right? Like, feeling like you're part of a squad that, like, is, like, that's such an exciting. So it's interesting. And both of you guys, it was kind of like that feeling of like, oh, I'm part of this. When everyone starts improvising the filing out, and Michael's still doing his animals. Right?
你身上的方式。这只是一种，我觉得，成为一件大事中的一小部分，是世界上最棒的感觉，对吧？就像感觉自己是某个团队的一部分，那种感觉太激动人心了。所以这很有趣。对你们俩来说，都是那种感觉：哦，我也是其中的一部分。当大家都开始即兴排队离开，而迈克尔还在继续他的动物梗时。对吧？
Or everyone's sort of slowly coming into the joining, showing up for the first time in the fictional office in a way. It was such a smart thing that Ken did by doing that exercise with us because we didn't start with a scene. Like we didn't start with, okay, Steve Correll, our lead character, Michael Scott is going to do a scene. he made every single one of us equally important in the very first thing we shot. Wow. You know, nobody had any lines, but everyone was in character, and you really felt how, okay, so whatever scene is going on, this is also always going on. So now we're going to do a scene, but don't forget, you all are still working in this office
或者大家以某种方式慢慢融入其中，第一次在这个虚构的办公室里亮相。肯通过让我们做那个练习所做的事情真是太聪明了，因为我们不是从一个场景开始的。我们不是从“好吧，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我们的主角，迈克尔·斯科特要演一场戏”开始的。他在我们拍摄的第一场戏里，让在场的每一个人都同样重要。哇。你知道的，没有人有台词，但每个人都沉浸在角色中，你真的能感受到，好吧，无论正在发生什么场景，这种日常状态也一直在发生。所以现在我们要拍一场戏了，但别忘了，你们所有人仍然在这个办公室里工作，
and you always have to be. It was really genius. That's cool. I think I missed that it was the first little. Literally the first thing you shot. The very first thing ever. First time the camera's rolled, right? Yeah.
而且你们必须时刻保持这种状态。这真的是天才之举。太酷了。我之前好像没意识到那是第一小段。字面意义上你们拍的第一场戏。有史以来拍的第一场镜头。摄像机转动的第一秒，对吧？
I know. Just give everyone a chance to kind of sort of what John did for me when I did that little talking head where it was like, okay, just like, I mean, that's different because I was like talking, but I just mean like giving a lot of space. Yes. Even though it was, even that's costly, you're making a pilot, like time is money, everything, right? But just to be like, we got time, we got space, just exist. And I also think because it was Ken, the very first time we were all in.
我知道。只是给每个人一个机会去融入，就像约翰为我做的那样，当我拍那个简短的“面对镜头独白”时，就好像，好吧，我的意思是，这不同，因为我当时在说话，但我的意思是给予足够的空间。是的。尽管这代价高昂，你在拍试播集，时间就是金钱，一切皆是如此，对吧？但只是说：我们有时间，我们有空间，尽管去存在吧。而且我也觉得因为那是肯，那是我们所有人第一次聚在
a room and we were all going to be these characters. No one yelled action. He just said, go ahead. Oh, that's nice. Because that's Ken, right? So he just said, go ahead. So it was just like this very slow, comfortable easing into this world. Did you ever see that John Cazale documentary? I knew it was. Do you know John Cazale, the guy who played Fredo? He was like in five movies and they were all like the best. He was like the Deer Hunter, Godfather went into the conversation. He died when he was a young man. But they made a documentary about him because he did these like, incredible movies and that's it he just did these and then theater and stuff but al Pacino oh he was in dog day afternoon al Pacino told these stories where they'd be like shooting on film and they would
一个房间里，而且我们都要扮演这些角色。没有人喊“Action”。他只是说：“开始吧。”哦，真好。因为那是肯，对吧？所以他只是说：“开始吧。”所以这就像是极其缓慢、舒适地融入这个世界。你们看过那部关于约翰·卡扎尔的纪录片吗？我知道那是。你知道约翰·卡扎尔吗？就是演弗雷多那个演员。他只演过五部电影，部部都是神作。他演过《猎鹿人》、《教父》，等等。他在很年轻的时候就去世了。但人们为他拍了一部纪录片，因为他拍了这些不可思议的电影，仅此而已，他只拍了这些，还有舞台剧什么的。阿尔·帕西诺，哦，他演过《热天午后》，阿尔·帕西诺讲过这样一个故事：当时他们正在用胶片拍摄，正准备
start rolling and al Pacino would be all kind of coiled up and do his line and he said this guy that John Castile would just be like what'd you do this weekend al and he'd hear the film moving through the camera and he'd be like uh I I don't know I like made dinner with my girlfriend on Saturday oh yeah what'd you make uh we made a regatone and, you know, oh, yeah, what did you have to that? And, like, just talk until, like, Al Pacino settled down. And then he'd just say, like, the first line of the scene where, like, he would just sort of get them in a place of, like, oh, we're just here.
开拍，阿尔·帕西诺整个人蓄势待发准备念台词，而他说，这个叫约翰·卡扎尔的家伙就会突然来一句：“你这个周末干嘛了，阿尔？”然后他能听到胶片在摄像机里走动的声音，就会说：“呃……我不知道，我周六跟我女朋友在家做饭来着。”“哦，是吗？你做了什么？”“呃……我们做了乳清干酪管面，然后呢……”“哦，是吗？你还吃了什么？”然后就这样一直聊天，直到阿尔·帕西诺平静下来。接着他才会说出那场戏的第一句台词，就好像他会把他们带入这样一种状态：哦，我们就在这里。
We're just here with each other. And then slowly sort of introduce the dialogue, which is, like, such a balsy, crazy thing to do. Where, like, 35-millimeter film is running through a camera. But I just was, like, it sounds like, in a version of that, right? We're just like, go ahead. Yeah, go ahead. We're not, it's not ready-set go. Hit your adding machine a few times.
我们只是彼此陪伴着。然后才慢慢引入对白，这真是一个极其大胆、疯狂的做法。当时可是有35毫米的胶片在摄像机里飞速运转呢。但我当时就觉得，这听起来像是那种版本的实践，对吧？就像是直接说：开始吧。是的，开始吧。我们不是在搞“预备、各就各位、跑”。去敲你的加法计算器几下吧。
Yeah. That's nice. Yeah. I feel bad. I feel like I've now extended. No. Are you kidding? I love this so much. It's just made my heart so happy.
这太棒了。是的。我觉得很不好意思。我觉得我把时间延长了。没有。开什么玩笑？我太喜欢这样了。这让我心里感到无比幸福。
Me too. Yeah. And I really, yeah, I can't say it enough. Like, it's a real talent I don't have, which is like to maintain, like, you know, did you ever see those, like, Richard Link later that like before sunset, before sunrise? Yeah, yeah. I love those movies. But that's sometimes what, like, shooting feels like to me where it's like this, like, very discreet, specific experience.
我也是。是的。而且我真的，是的，我怎么强调都不为过。这真的是我所不具备的一种天赋，那就是去维持，你知道的，你见过理查德·林克莱特的那几部电影吗，比如《爱在黎明破晓前》、《爱在日落黄昏时》？对，对。我太喜欢那些电影了。但那就是有时拍摄给我的感觉，就像是一种非常微妙、具体的体验，
experience of like real like big emotion intimacy connection and then you're like off to your lives and you don't to me it often feels that way where it's like it's like this amazing one night stand or something except it happened to be a two year stand but um and so i feel like i've kind of lost touch with you know you guys and this larger squad but i can just never say enough how much it meant that everyone was so kind. I just, in a way that you guys stood to gain nothing from that. I had nothing to offer you. And in a way, I could have been either in your, like, I could have been a problem in that it's like another mouth to feed on this big show. Like, but that was not how I was received. And that really set the tone and for the rest of my working life thus
体验到真实而巨大的情感、亲密感和连接，然后你就各自回归生活。对我来说，这种感觉经常出现，就像是一夜情或者别的什么，只不过恰好持续了两年，但是……所以我觉得我好像和你们以及这个更大的团队渐渐失去了联系，但我永远无法表达足够的感激，感激大家是如此善良。在某种程度上，你们从我身上捞不到任何好处。我没有什么可以提供给你们的。从某种程度上讲，我甚至可能会成为你们的负担，因为在这个大制作里多了一张要喂养的嘴。但这并不是我受到的待遇。这真的为我余下的职业生涯奠定了基调，
far. And it's, so I just, yeah, I don't know. I just want. I felt, when you guys kindly invited me on, I was like, I want to say to people, I want people who like the show to know how kind the people who worked on the show were and are, you know. You know, I think we were happy, Zach. Like, we were a happy cast. We were a happy crew. And we just knew, like, there's enough to go around for everyone. There just is. There always is.
到目前为止都是如此。所以，我只是，是的，我不知道。我只是想。当你们好心邀请我来时，我想对大家说，我想让喜欢这部剧的人知道，曾经参与这部剧的人是多么善良，现在也依然善良，你知道的。你知道，我觉得我们很开心，扎克。我们是一个快乐的演员阵容。我们是一个快乐的剧组。我们知道，在这个世界上，人人都有份。确实如此。一直都是如此。
In good comedy and good art, you do not need to be stingy. It's a collective. It is. And it was an abundant universe. And I think we all looked at it that way. We always felt like we won the lottery. We always talk about that. And I think everyone felt that way.
在优秀的喜剧和优秀的艺术中，你不需要吝啬。这是一个集体。确实如此。那是一个资源丰富的宇宙。我想我们都是这么看的。我们总是觉得自己中了彩票。我们经常这么说。而且我觉得每个人都有这种感觉。
So why not share it? A lot of lottery winners hire, like, private security and, like, a bunch of Dobermans and shit. You guys were like, you know, you guys were like the good lottery winners. Oh, Zach, thank you so much for coming on. Thank you for having me. It was really fun. What are you doing now that we can tell people about? I'm making this stop motion show.
所以为什么不分享呢？很多中彩票的人都会雇私人保镖和一群杜宾犬什么的。你们就像是那种，你们就像是中彩票的人里最好的一拨人。哦，扎克，非常感谢你能来。谢谢你们邀请我。这真的很有趣。你现在在做什么我们可以跟听众分享的吗？我在做一个定格动画秀。
Actually, Greg Daniels is, like, he's, it's his company, but it's, is one of the producers on. It's a stop motion show about an NPR host. So I'm doing that right now, and that'll come out. Are you the voice of the NPR host? Yeah. Amazing. You'll have to let us know when it comes out and where people can find it and we're going to share it. Oh, that's so sweet.
事实上，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）是，这是他的公司，但他也是其中一位制片人。这是一个关于国家公共广播电台（NPR）主持人的定格动画秀。所以我现在在做这个，它将会上映。你是NPR主持人的配音吗？对。太棒了。到时候你得告诉我们它什么时候上映，大家可以在哪里看到它，我们会把它分享出去的。哦，太贴心了。
Yeah. But anyway, thanks for having me on. It was really a treat. It's so nice to reconnect with you guys. It's so nice to see you. Love you, Zach. Yeah, you too. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
对。总之，谢谢你们邀请我来。这真是一次享受。能和你们重新连线真是太美妙了。见到你们太好了。爱你们，扎克。是的，我也是。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西共同制作。我们的高级制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑与混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制片人是艾因斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。